programming throwdown episode 103 working from home with adam bell take it away jason hey everybody so um this is a pretty interesting episode we're uh we're actually uh live on twitch and so this is something we tried patrick what maybe five years ago or something a really long time ago um and uh you know i don't know why did we stop recording to twitch i think i think part of it was we got a lot more engagement on Discord, and the Twitch just couldn't seem to kick off. But since then, especially recently, a lot of folks have been saying, oh, we kind of want to see the podcast on either Twitch or YouTube or one of these platforms. And so we're going to give it a second go. We'll record some episodes on Twitch, and we'll see how it goes.
编程闲聊第 103 期：与亚当·贝尔（Adam Bell）探讨居家办公，把话筒交给杰森。嗨，大家好，嗯……这是一个相当有趣的节目，我们实际上是在 Twitch 上进行直播，所以这是我们大概，帕特里克，也许五年前或类似的时候尝试过的事情，是很久很久以前了，而且……你知道的，我不知道为什么我们停止在 Twitch 上录音？我想，部分原因是因为我们在 Discord 上获得了更多的互动，而 Twitch 似乎一直火不起来。但从那以后，尤其是最近，很多人一直在说：“哦，我们其实挺想在 Twitch、YouTube 或其中某个平台上看到这个播客的。”所以我们要再试一次。我们将在 Twitch 上录制一些节目，看看效果如何。
It really depends on you, our loyal fans, to let us know if this medium gives some extra value. Yeah, I think Twitch has grown a lot. And also, especially these days, which I'm sure we're going to talk about in a few minutes, I think people's appetite for consuming online content has only been going up. Yeah, yeah, totally. Yeah, a lot of people ask us why we use Skype and not Zoom.
这完全取决于你们，我们忠实的粉丝，来让我们知道这种媒介是否能带来额外的价值。是的，我认为 Twitch 发展了很多，而且，特别是现在这段时间，我确信我们几分钟后就会聊到这个，我认为人们对消费在线内容的胃口一直在增长。是的，是的，完全同意。是的，很多人问我们为什么用 Skype 而不用 Zoom。
And I think the answer, correct me if I'm wrong, Patrick, is just that we never tried Zoom. I mean, we've been doing this podcast longer than Zoom's been around. Oh, that's true, too. Yeah, that's very true. But you get some inside baseball. You know, we do a Skype call. We record it through Skype. And also Patrick does some recording. And then we kind of mix it all together afterwards. But anyway, so today we have Adam, and we're going to all chat about working from home, which is something we've all been doing a lot of lately. And it's something that Adam personally has been doing for, what, nine years full time,
我想答案是——如果我错了请纠正我，帕特里克——只是我们从来没用过 Zoom。我的意思是，我们做这个播客的时间比 Zoom 存在的时间还要长。哦，这也是真的。是的，非常真实。但你会得到一些内幕消息。你知道，我们进行 Skype 通话，通过 Skype 录制，帕特里克也会进行一些录制，然后我们在事后把它们混合在一起。不管怎样，今天我们有亚当（Adam），我们要一起聊聊居家办公，这是我们最近都在做很多的事情，这也是亚当个人一直在做的事情，有多久了，全职九年？
which is way longer than either of us. And so I'm sure you're going to have a ton of insights. But yeah, maybe Adam,, you could start kick it off by just talking about, like, what made you work from home? Like, was it your decision? Or is it something that was circumstantial? And what kind of started that? Yeah, great question. Yeah, so in 2011, like I live in Peterborough, Ontario, Canada, it's got like 85,000 people. It's not the tech hub that you hear about, right? So I had a boss who had left and went to work somewhere else, actually in Waterloo area in Ontario. And he wanted me to come work for him.
这比我们俩的时间都要长得多，所以我确信你会有大量的见解。但是，亚当，也许你可以先聊聊是什么让你开始居家办公的？比如，这是你自己的决定，还是环境使然？是什么促成了这一开始？是的，好问题。所以在 2011 年，我住在加拿大安大略省彼得伯勒，那里大概有 85,000 人，它可不是你听说的那种科技中心，对吧？所以我有个老板离职去了别的地方工作，实际上是在安大略省的滑铁卢地区，他想让我去为他工作。
And he said, like, hey, maybe you could do it remote because I didn't want to move there. And so I took a day off work. I drove down there. I did all these interviews. And he said at the beginning, kind of like, oh, so they're going to want you to say you're moving here. But like, it's all cool, which was a little weird. Oh, no. So I went through like all the interviews and then I met with HR last and she was like, OK, so when are you thinking of moving to Waterloo?
他说：“嘿，也许你可以远程工作。”因为我不想搬到那里去。所以我请了一天假，开车到那儿，进行了所有这些面试。他一开始就说：“哦，所以他们会想让你说你要搬到这里来，但没关系，一切都好，”这感觉有点奇怪。哦，不。所以我完成了所有的面试，然后最后我见到了 HR，她说：“好的，那你打算什么时候搬到滑铁卢呢？”
And I was like, well, you know, I'm not like I think if you want to say that I'm moving here, then that's fine. But, you know, I'm not. And she's like, I don't know what you're talking about. This job is for here. So it became a whole thing. I drove home thinking I didn't get the job, which seemed like a great job. And then like my former manager phoned me up and said, I heard there was some sort of misunderstanding. We're happy to have you work remote. Let's get you an offer. Got me an offer. And he said, now the offer says that you're going to be working in Waterloo, but just ignore that. So I took a huge gamble and I took that job and I never went to the office. Well, actually, I went a couple times, but I started working from my small apartment that I lived in with my now wife. And I think within a week,
我说：“嗯，你知道，我没有……我想如果你想说我要搬到这里来，那也没问题，但是，你知道，我没有。”她说：“我不知道你在说什么，这份工作是给这里的人的。”所以这变成了一件大事。我开车回家，以为我没得到这份工作，这看起来本是一份很棒的工作。然后我以前的经理打电话给我说：“我听说有什么误解，我们很高兴你能远程工作，让我们给你发个Offer。”于是给我发了 Offer。他说：“现在 Offer 上写着你将在滑铁卢工作，但别管那个。”所以我冒了巨大的风险，接受了那份工作，并且从未去过办公室。好吧，实际上我去过几次，但我开始在我跟我现在的妻子住的小公寓里工作，我想在一周之内，
I was like, I don't think I want to go back to working in an office. I think that maybe, you know, the times we're in right now are a little bit strange. It's not the ideal working from home times. But back then when I tried it, I was like, this is a really good fit for my, you know, for who I am, for my personality, for the way I like to work. And so it's years later, I've been at three or four different companies, all remote. So like dive into that a bit. Like what makes your personality or anyone's personality good for working from home? And what would make it bad? Yeah, that's a good question. So like, I think the thing that is the worst for working remotely isn't really a personality thing, but an experience thing. I work on a team that's distributed right now. I think it's really hard if you don't have
我就觉得：“我不想再回办公室上班了。”我想也许，你知道，我们现在身处的时代有点奇怪，这不是居家办公的理想时期。但当年我尝试的时候，我就觉得：“这非常适合我的，你知道的，适合我的性格，适合我喜欢的工作方式。”所以多年以后，我在三四家不同的公司工作过，全都是远程的。所以，深入探讨一下这个话题吧，是什么让你的性格或任何人的性格适合居家办公？什么又不适合呢？是的，这是个好问题。所以，我觉得对远程工作最不利的因素其实不是性格问题，而是经验问题。我目前在一个分布式团队工作，我觉得如果你没有
experience like working in an office place, like maybe there's a way to do that. But I think that's the hardest thing, right? If you just finished school or something, you just finished university or grad school, and you're like, I'm starting a new job, and it's just you at home on your couch. Like, I don't think I don't know how you're going to learn, like what what a day's work looks like, like what the expectations are, like when you should ask for help. So that's like the biggest area that I don't think we've figured out how to work from home. The other thing I would say is just like, you know, like some people like to be really social. I'm probably maybe a bit less social than some. Like I think I can get by, you know, with a lower level of like water cooler chat. I mean, some people, I mean, I don't think some people might not realize that that's who they are until, you know, like our present situation where they're like, you know, I'm really struggling without, without the needed social contact. Um, also like I had a significant other that I lived with at home. I think if, if you lived by yourself
在办公室工作的经验，这会非常困难，或许有其他方法可以做到这一点，但我觉得这是最难的，对吧？如果你刚毕业什么的，刚读完大学或研究生，然后你觉得：“我要开始一份新工作，而只有你一个人在家里的沙发上。”我不觉得……我不知道你该怎么去学习，比如一天的工作是什么样的，期望是什么时候应该寻求帮助。所以这是我们觉得还没搞清楚怎么进行居家办公的最大领域。我要说的另一件事是，你知道，有些人非常喜欢社交。我可能比某些人稍微少一点社交。我觉得我可以应付，你知道的，较低水平的闲聊。我是说，有些人，我的意思是，有些人可能直到现在这种我们面对的情况出现时，才意识到这就是他们的本性，他们会说：“你知道，没有了必要的社交接触，我真的很难受。”还有，如果家里有伴侣一起住的话……如果你一个人住，
and work was your main like social outlet um i think that could be a struggle right yep yep yeah it totally makes sense i mean it totally resonates with me i think uh um i think along the same lines i wonder you know like people who are starting now uh you have to work from home so so you graduated from college back in uh uh probably i guess now maybe you graduated from college two weeks ago or something, and you got your first job and you're working remote, right? And I think it's a huge, huge challenge. And so another thing you said that resonated with me is this idea, like, we haven't really got it right. I totally agree with that. You know, I was thinking about how, you know, when you're sitting around the same desk, like in some
而工作又是你主要的社交渠道，我想那会很艰难，对吧？对，对，对，这完全说得通。我的意思是，这完全引起了我的共鸣。我觉得，呃……我觉得沿着同样的思路，我想知道，你知道，现在开始工作的人，你必须居家办公，所以——你大学毕业，呃，大概，我猜现在你可能两周前刚大学毕业什么的，你找到了第一份工作，你在远程工作，对吧？我觉得这是一个巨大、巨大的挑战。所以，你说的另一件引起我共鸣的事情是这种想法，即我们还没有真正把它弄对。我完全同意这一点。我在想，当你们坐在同一个办公桌旁，比如在某种
bullpen environment, you can just run over and talk to somebody or you can ask a question, right? You know, I don't think you can completely remove your privacy when you're at home. You can't just have a camera staring at you 24-7. It's just super awkward, right? But maybe, you know, one thing that might be better than what we have now is maybe like maybe like a set of hours like office hours type thing where you say like from one to two my camera is always on and uh so is yours and so there's this grid maybe of all of our faces for that hour and then it turns off something like that um yeah but there's that's one of probably a thousand ideas we could come up with brainstorming here today on how to make it better. I mean, I think there's huge amounts of progress that needs to be made. on Slack or whatever, you know, like a place where I see like working from home go badly is like people who might hash something out for 20 minutes in the office will spend three hours like talking
开放式办公环境中，你可以直接跑过去和某人交谈，或者你可以问一个问题，对吧？你知道，当你在家时，你无法完全消除你的隐私，你不能只是让一个摄像头 24/7 盯着你，这实在是太尴尬了，对吧？但也许，你知道，有一件可能比我们现在的状况更好的事情，也许是一套固定的时间，类似于办公时间那种，你说：“从一点到两点，我的摄像头总是开着的，你的也是，所以在那个小时里，我们所有人的面孔可能会组成这样一个网格，然后它就会关闭，”类似这样的事情……是的，但这可能是我们今天在这里头脑风暴想出的关于如何让它变得更好的成千上万个想法之一。我的意思是，我认为有大量的进展需要在 Slack 或其他什么地方取得。你知道，我看到居家办公搞砸的一个地方是，在办公室里花 20 分钟就能争论清楚的事情，人们却要在 Slack 上花三个小时来讨论。就像，直接开个语音通话吧。我知道看起来他们不在，但就假装他们在，然后把它谈清楚。
about it on Slack. Like, just like jump on a call. Like, I know it seems like they're not there, but just pretend they are and like, and talk it out. Yeah, what about like, I feel like I get notification overload now that I'm working from home. And I mean, similar to what you were just saying, where instead of just having someone on the shoulder, you send them a message and then it's just N squared problem, right? How do you deal with notification overload? Yeah, I mean, I think it's hard. I think the same kind of like office hours kind of concept could work i know yeah um like i talked to somebody at my work who kind of their like role is like half you know like like doing a lot of work and half just like
是的，那关于——我觉得现在居家办公让我收到了太多的通知轰炸。我的意思是，类似于你刚才说的，不用去拍别人的肩膀，而是发个消息，然后这就成了一个 $N^2$ 的问题，对吧？你是如何应对通知轰炸的？是的，我的意思是，我觉得这很难。我觉得同样的“办公时间”概念可以起作用。我知道，是的……就像我跟我工作中的某个人聊过，他们的角色大概是一半时间，你知道，在做大量的工作，另一半时间只是在与人开会，
kind of meeting with people um you know kind of half manager half individual contributor and they said like they actually split their day literally in half and say like this time you know there's no notifications there's no whatever here's my you know my there's no notifications, there's no whatever, here's my, you know, my deep thinking time. And then here's where I'm whatever, telling this person to talk to this person or, or chatting. Yeah. Another thing is like, so my, yeah, like, so my wife works right now, you know, she's on a bit of a different schedule because of the times we're in. But like, you know, for the for the nine years that I've been at home, like she has like a fairly standard nine to five job. So she like, you know, we get up at the same time when she leaves. That's kind of like I'm in my work zone. Right. And when she comes home,
有点像一半是经理，一半是独立贡献者，他们说他们实际上把一天的时间字面意义上切成两半，说在这个时间段，没有通知，没有别的，这就是我的……没有通知，没有别的，这就是我的深度思考时间。然后在这里我是什么什么，告诉这个人去跟那个人谈话，或者聊天。是的。另一件事是，所以我的……是的，就像，我妻子现在在工作，你知道的，因为我们目前的时代，她的时间表有点不同。但是，你知道，在我呆在家的九年里，她有一份相当标准的朝九晚五的工作。所以她——你知道的，我们在同一时间起床，她离开。那就好像我进入了工作状态，对吧。而当她回家时，
it's kind of the end of my work day. So, I mean, I didn't come up with this strategy. That's just kind of how my life works. But I think it's it's really important if you're working from home to have some sort of bookends. Because otherwise, people think that the danger is people at home aren't working. But I think the real danger is just that work becomes pervasive in your entire life and you can't turn it off. Yeah, right. Yeah, I think that and also people don't know how much you're working. So we're in a research team. And so there's a there's people don't know how much you're working. So, you know, we're in a research team. And so there's a lot of folks doing research on things that ultimately don't pan out.
差不多就是我工作日的结束。所以，我的意思是，我不是想出这个策略的，这只是我的生活运作方式。但我觉得如果你居家办公，有某种收尾阶段真的很重要。因为否则，人们认为危险在于在家的人不工作，但我认为真正的危险只是工作渗透到了你生活的方方面面，你无法关掉它。是的，没错。是的，我觉得还有人们不知道你工作了多少。所以我们在一个研究团队里，所以有……人们不知道你工作了多少。所以，你知道，我们在一个研究团队里，所以有很多人在研究最终没有成功的事情。
And so when you're sitting right next to somebody, you see them, you know, sweating and then they're writing on the Expo marker board and they erase it with their hand and then they rub the sweat off their head. And now they have like a rainbow on their forehead. And they're just like they're just crazy like like stressed out and you say okay well you know at least i know for a fact that this person is putting in a lot of effort um and then maybe nothing comes to that which is really a shame but like at least you kind of have an idea versus now and it works the other way too sometimes you get this eureka moment and uh and you do things that you didn't even have to put a lot of effort into. And so that becomes harder to sort of internalize when you're not around the person. Yeah, yeah, totally. And I
所以当你坐在某人旁边时，你看着他们，你知道的，他们在大汗淋漓，然后在记号笔白板上写字，然后用手擦掉，接着把额头上的汗抹掉。现在他们的额头上就像有一道彩虹。他们就像是疯狂地、压力山大，你会说：“好吧，你知道，至少我可以确定这个人付出了大量的努力，”然后也许并没有什么成果，这真的很遗憾，但至少你心里有个底，而现在情况则相反，有时候你会突然灵光一现，你做的事情甚至不需要付出太多的努力。所以当你不在那个人身边时，这就变得更难以内化了。是的，是的，完全如此。而且我
don't know, like, you have to have a certain amount of buy-in from, I guess, the organization and the people you work with, I guess, right? I don't work in a research type environment, but I assume that if you do, and if you're going to be not in an office, then there needs to be some sort of understanding, you know, that this is how it is, right? Otherwise, like, yeah, if you have to dedicate your hard thinking time to making sure you're, you know, demonstrating some sort of output so that you can be measured, I don't think that's going to help anything. Yeah, totally. So Patrick, what's your experience been like? So Patrick works at a place where almost nobody ever worked from home. So at my job, we worked from home on Wednesdays,
不知道，比如，你必须得到组织和你共事的人的一定程度的认可，我想是这样的吧？我不在研究型环境工作，但我假设如果你在，而且如果你不在办公室，那么就需要有一种共识，你知道，情况就是这样，对吧？否则，是的，如果你必须把你的深度思考时间花在确保你正在展示某种产出以便被衡量上，我不认为这会对任何事情有帮助。是的，完全同意。那么，帕特里克，你的体验是怎样的？所以帕特里克在一个几乎没有人居家办公的地方工作。所以在我的工作场所，我们在周三居家办公，
way before a virus hit. But Patrick, working from home is kind of anathema to your company. And so what has it been like? It must be a huge change. Yeah, I mean, I think this is an interesting question for teams that are like mine. And I think you guys have been sort of alluding to a lot of the same things we're all going through. But companies that didn't have extensive work from home experience before, it's a lot harder of a transition. I actually think we've adapted pretty quickly but most of the team has been stable been working together for a while so they already kind of know what everyone's doing without having to talk about it as much um
早在病毒袭来之前很久就是这样。但是帕特里克，居家办公对你的公司来说简直是一种异端，所以情况是怎样的？这一定是一个巨大的改变。是的，我的意思是，我认为对于像我这样的团队来说，这是一个有趣的问题。而且我认为你们一直在暗示很多我们都在经历的事情。但是对于以前没有丰富的居家办公经验的公司来说，这是一个艰难得多的过渡。我其实觉得我们适应得相当快，但大部分团队都很稳定，已经一起工作了一段时间，所以他们基本上不用多说什么就已经知道每个人在做什么了，
onboarding new people has been slightly more challenging adjusting to them but we've done the the things like we're talking about like just have an hour every day or a little longer and just be on a chat and shoot the breeze or talk about specifics and people can sign off if they want, but new people tend to not have as much work to do. So they have a little more time to be able to hang out. And it's important, I think, to be able to get them that time, even if it doesn't seem directly beneficial to having them churn out lines of code. I think it's important to have people get adjusted pretty quickly. And so that's how we've been tackling it. It's actually been working out, I think, better than if you had
新员工的入职培训稍微更具挑战性，适应他们也有难度，但我们一直在做我们谈论过的事情，比如每天花一个小时或稍微长一点的时间，在一个聊天室里闲聊或讨论具体细节，如果人们愿意的话可以签退，但新员工往往没有那么多工作要做。所以他们有更多的时间可以闲逛。而且我认为，能够给他们腾出这些时间是很重要的，即使这看起来对他们疯狂敲代码没有直接的好处。我认为让人们相当快地适应是很重要的事情。这就是我们一直在应对它的方式。实际上，效果比如果你在开始时问我“这会进展得怎样”时我要好，我本来会预测情况会更糟。而且我认为这是很多人正在意识到的一点，即对于那些以前说可能不想居家办公或这对他们不重要的人来说，情况并没有他们想象的那么糟糕。他们意识到：“哦，实际上，这有很多优势。”但随后，是的，很多人都在说：“是的，我其实没有为此准备好一个好的家庭配置。”
asked me at the start, how is this going to go? I would have predicted it going worse. And I think that's a realization a lot of people are coming to is that it's not as bad as they thought it would be for the people who said maybe they didn't want to work from home or it wasn't important to them before. They're realizing, oh, actually, there's kind of a lot of advantages to this. But then, yeah, a lot of people are saying, yeah, I don't really have a good home set up for this.
比如，“我没有家庭办公室。这个空间里有太多其他人了。”所以对这些人来说，当然，这更像是一种挣扎。所以展望未来，我认为有趣的事情是，如果人们相信这种情况发生的概率更高，他们可能会选择如何调整。所以人们可能会选择他们住在哪里，或者不住在哪里，他们买什么样的公寓，或者不买什么样的公寓，
Like, I don't have a home office. I have too many other people in this space. And so for those people, of course, like it's more of a struggle. And so looking forward, I think the interesting thing is how people may choose to adjust if they believe there's a higher probability of this happening. So people may select where they live or not live or what kind of apartment they get or don't get
或者他们买什么样的房子，或者不买什么样的房子。认为居家办公可能会更频繁地发生，或者我们可能会被迫居家办公，你管这叫什么，我想这就是近因效应，就像它以前从未发生过，但现在发生了，所以未来更有可能发生，虽然我实际上不必……但我认为很多人会这样对待它。是的，这说得通。是的，我的意思是，有很多东西需要剖析。我觉得，呃……是的，有一件事就是这种“在任何地方工作”的想法，我认为这将对整个行业造成巨大的颠覆。我指的颠覆不是坏事，比如颠覆你的服务什么的，而是我认为它将从根本上改变整个行业。最终，我认为是朝着更好的方向改变。但我想，你知道的，如果你想想招聘漏网之鱼——招聘漏斗，我的意思是，它将不得不完全改变，对吧？
or house they buy or don't buy. Thinking that work from home may happen more often, or maybe we may be forced into work from home, which what do you call i guess that's a recency bias like it's never happened before but it happened now so it's more likely to happen in the future but i don't actually have to but i think a lot of people will treat it that way yeah that makes sense yeah i mean there's a lot to unpack there i think uh um yeah one thing is is this this idea of of um working anywhere i I think that that is going to be a huge disruption to the entire industry. And I don't mean disruption in a bad way, like disrupting your service or something, but I think it's going to radically change the entire industry. Ultimately, I think for the better. But I think, you know, if you think about the recruiting funnel, I mean, it's going to have to completely change, right?
我的意思是，过去你有这种地域偏好。所以，你知道，我们想要在这个城市工作的人。因此，会搬到那个城市的人数很少。所以你的流程、你的漏斗永远不会变得太大而无法做任何事情来管理它。然后，此外，你可以对你的漏斗采取非常激进的态度，因为作为一个公司，你的发展规模和速度是有限的，对吧？但现在，你知道，如果我们真的走向这种完全分布式的模式，那么我们必须想办法为世界各地的工作岗位接收来自世界各地的人的简历，以及如何在世界各地以一种具有竞争力的方式支付薪水。我的意思是，
I mean, it used to be that you had this locality bias. So, you know, we want people who work in this city. And so the amount of people who will relocate to that city is small. And so your process, your funnel doesn't ever get too big that you can't do anything, you know, to manage it. And then, and furthermore, like you could be really aggressive in how you do your funnel because you can only grow so big as a company so quickly, right? But now, you know, if we really go to this totally distributed model, then we have to figure out ways to field resumes from people all over the world for jobs all over the world and how to pay people in a competitive way around the world. I mean,
所有这些事情都必须在接下来的六个月里得到解决。我认为有一句名言，关于未来已经到来，只是分布不均。这就像有些地方一直都在正确地这样做……只是它一直不是常态，对吧？我想如果你看看很多一直在招聘并且是分布式办公的地方，有时是因为他们有某种特定的细分领域，比如你知道，如果你需要非常特定的那种人，也许他们并不都在同一个地方，对吧？所以你会想：“嘿，我需要世界上最优秀的人，其中两个在英国伦敦，一个在爱达荷州。”然后你就去适应它。帕特里克提到的另一件有趣的事情是关于你希望拥有的那种环境，比如你的工作生活，对吧？我想当我开始居家办公时，我有套公寓，那是一套两居室的公寓，我抽出了一些时间——我的意思是，人们这次没有这个机会——我在工作间隙请了假，把第二间卧室里的所有垃圾都清出去，你知道的，我建立了一个特定的办公室，我想这张桌子就是我的工作桌。而且我认为在一个更多人像这样工作的世界里，城市地区的公寓与拥有一个可以腾出一些额外空间的巨大房子相比，可能有一些劣势，至少在工作方面是这样。在其他领域有某些好处，但我确实认为这会改变人们的一些偏好。所以你如何……哦，请继续，帕特里克。
all of that stuff is going to have to get figured out in the next six months. I think there's like, you know, the quote about the future is here. It's just unevenly distributed. It's like places have been doing this right um they've just it's not been the norm right like i think if you look at a lot of the places that that have been hiring and been distributed like sometimes it's because they have like a certain particular niche where it's like you know if you need you know very specific uh type of people like maybe they're not all in one area, right? So you're like, hey, I need the best people in the world. And there's like two of them in London,
是的，我有这个，我不知道你叫它什么，一种关于这个事情的个人理论，但我会在这里当着一大群人的面讲出来，这会很棒，那就是——我刚才在说，我思考它的方式，这引起了我的共鸣（我想我是有偏见的），就是当人们住在非常城市化的环境中时，他们的房子更小，但他们愿意支付更多，因为娱乐和生活部分是在他们的房子外面进行的。就像他们不需要大厨房，因为他们在好餐馆吃饭。所以如果你住在纽约市曼哈顿，对吧，那超级贵，公寓很小，但在步行距离之内有太多事情可做了。你有一个房子，它是你公寓内部和街角小卖部你喜欢去吃东西的当地某某商店之间的混合体，那是你的食品储藏室，你知道，所有这些东西都在你附近，你可以去各种世界上最好的娱乐场所，而不是仅仅坐在家里，看着一个相对较小的电视看电视，因为你没有空间，所以你愿意支付更多，因为你不是在把外包作为正确的词，而是在利用公寓外面的空间作为你的生活空间，公园，
England, and one is in Idaho. And then so you just kind of adapt to that. Another interesting thing that Patrick said is like about like the type of environments you want to have, like for your work life right i think like when i started working from home um like i had an apartment it was a two-bedroom apartment i took like i mean people didn't have this opportunity this time like i took off some time between work i got all the crap out of my second bedroom you know like i set up a specific office and i was like this desk is my is my work desk um and i think that in a world where more people are working like this, apartments probably in urban areas have some disadvantages compared to getting a large house
你知道，娱乐场所，而如果你住在郊区，你需要一个更大的房子，因为那些娱乐东西搬到了你的住宅内部。所以你需要娱乐你和你的家人。如果你有孩子或宠物，你需要在你的房子里做到这一点，因为你不想总是上车到处开车。所以当你看到这些封锁发生时，你家外面的娱乐空间被剥夺了访问权，这就好像有人进来，用生物危害胶带封锁了你的一部分房子，并告诉你不再被允许使用它。然后在某个时刻，
where you could have some extra space, at least in terms of work. There's certain benefits in other areas, but I think it does change some of the preferences people would have. So how do you... Oh, go ahead, Patrick. Yeah, I have this, I don't know you call like a pet theory about the like thing but i'll tell it here in front of a giant crowd of people it'd be great um which is i was saying that uh the way i was thinking about it which resonated with me i guess i'm biased is uh when people live in like very urban environments they have smaller houses but they're willing to pay more because the entertainment living portions are
你会觉得：“嗯，这是一个骗局，这是一个敲诈。当我无法访问我一直认为是我生活一部分的东西以及我为此付费的原因时，我不想支付这些价格。我为什么还要留在这里？我为什么要支付这个？”如果你把价格压得足够低，我想市场需求会表明人们仍然会选择它。但其他许多人要么价格需要降低，要么我要离开，因为我被剥夺了访问我一直认为的居住空间的一部分的权利，特别是对于居家办公之类的事情，这变得更加困难，因为你住在这样一个地方：也许你仍然需要通勤什么的，但你工作的地方是你的办公室，现在你不能去那个办公室，而且你没有别的选择，因为你的住所里没有
conducted outside of their house. Like they don't need a big kitchen because they eat out at nice restaurants. So if you live in New York City, Manhattan, right, like that's uber expensive, small apartment, but there's so much to do just within walking distance. You have a house that's a hybrid between inside your apartment and like the local whatever shop that you like to eat at down the street in the bodega on the corner is your pantry and you know you have all of these things very near to you go to all sorts of some of the world's best entertainment rather than just sitting at home and and watching tv on a relatively small tv because you have no space and so you're willing to pay more because you're not outsourcing is the right word, but you're utilizing space outside of your apartment as your living space, the park,
备用空间。对于这些人来说，我认为他们会对此产生非常剧烈的反应，就像他们需要立即解决一样。因为坐在床边工作只能持续几个小时，然后你就会意识到这是不可持续的。是的，一定有一个中间地带，对吧？每个人都搬到中等规模的地方。每个人都住在博尔德或圣路易斯，并且有一个共享办公空间，对吧？就像某种中间地带，你觉得：“我有更多的空间，而且我可以分享一些城市便利设施。”我不知道。是的，这说得通。是的。我工作的地方有很多人提出了这个想法：
you know, entertainment venues versus if you live in the suburbs, you need a bigger house because that entertainment stuff moves inside of your domicile. So you need to entertain you and your family. And if you have children or pets, you need to do that sort of within your house because you don't want to get in your car and drive everywhere all the time. And so when you see these lockdowns that are happening where the entertainment spaces outside of your house are being denied access to you, it's like someone coming in and like, you know, biohazard taping off part of your house and telling you're no longer allowed to use this. And then at some point,
他们想在内布拉斯加州度过一年的六个月，然后在工作所在的曼哈顿度过另外六个月。这引发了一系列有趣的问题。所以现在你可以说：“好吧，没问题，我们会付给你，比方说，内布拉斯加州的市场汇率，当你在内布拉斯加州时，软件工程师在内布拉斯加州赚多少钱就付多少。”但如果你仔细想想，这又回到了我们不久前讨论过的一些问题，关于某样东西的实际价值是什么，以及你是如何弄清楚这一点的？还有，你知道，
you're going to go like, well, this is a scam. This is a rip off. I don't want to pay these prices when I can't access what I was considering part of my living and the reason why I was paying for this. Like, why am I still here? Why am I paying this? And if you drop prices low enough, I guess the market demand will say like people will do some people will still choose that. But a bunch of other people are going to go either their price needs to get lower or I'm going to leave because i'm being denied access to part of like what i was considering my living space and especially for things like work from home that gets even harder because you lived in an area where maybe you still had to commute or whatever but you had the place where you worked was your office and now you can't go to that office and you have no alternative because you don't have
这个工程师对公司的实际价值实际上上升了，因为他们使用的物理空间更少了，并且完成了同样多的工作，但如果你采取市场价格的态度，你最终会付给他们更少，对吧？因此，这两种衡量某物价值的方法之间最终会出现某种脱节，对吧？是的，我认为整个事情，还有，我想这一切都联系在一起。如果在招聘方面，我们现在能够在内布拉斯加州找到一堆超级有才华的人，那么这确实会给身处城市的人带来巨大的下行压力。正如帕特里克所说，为了拥有相同的生活质量，他们需要大量这些额外的便利设施，对吧？而在内布拉斯加州，这些都是资本支出，我想。是的，我觉得整件事都很有趣。我想我确实看到很多……人们重新开始关注家具，以及适应居家办公的舒适度。我确实看到很多人
spare space in your place of residence and for for those people, I think they develop a very acute reaction to this where it's like they need an immediate fix. Because working from sitting on the edge of your bed is only going to happen for a few hours before you realize it's not sustainable. Yeah, there must be a middle ground, right? Where everybody moves to the medium size. Everybody lives in Boulder or St. Louis and has a co-working place, right? Like some middle ground where you're like, I have more space and I can share some urban amenities. And I don't know. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. A number of people where I work have brought up this idea that
在购买——我实际上也买了一个——比如这种可以在家里上下升降的机械桌。那是我在工作时经常使用的东西。我以为这需要花一大笔钱，但实际上，它们的价格已经降下来了。你可以以相当合理的价格买到一个。到目前为止，我认为这对我来说是居家办公最大的改善，那就是买了一个可以站立办公的桌子。是的，我也有一个站立式办公桌。是的，我几年前买的，我从不后悔。尽管我花了很多时间坐在它前面。
they want to spend six months of the year in Nebraska and then the other six months in Manhattan where the job is. And that raises a bunch of interesting questions. So right now you could say, well, okay, we'll pay you, let's say, market rate for Nebraska, whatever a software engineer makes in Nebraska when you're in Nebraska. But then if you think about it, this gets back to something we talked about a while ago about like, what is something actually worth and how you figure that out? Also, you know,
是的，我想对于播客来说，坐着可能是最好的。我认为市场动态的事情很有趣。我好像在网上看到过一些言论，说软件开发人员的市场将会变得更加分裂。对的。我的意思是，这是一个理论，因为如果我住在内布拉斯加州，而你试图付给我内布拉斯加州的本地工资，但我实际上有来自其他湾区公司的竞争报价，你就会直接付给我湾区的薪酬水平。对吧。但如果我没有，那么我就会拿到内布拉斯加州的工资水平。随着这种情况慢慢蔓延开来，我认为这只意味着有需求的开发人员会获得非常高的薪资档次，而
what this engineer is actually worth to the company actually goes up because they're using less physical space and getting the same amount of work done, but you're going to end up paying them less if you take the market price attitude, right? And so there ends up being this sort of disconnect between these two ways of measuring what something is worth, right? And yeah, I think this whole, there's also, I guess it all kind of ties together. If on the recruiting side, we're now able to find a bunch of super talented folks in Nebraska, then that really puts a lot of downward pressure on people who are in the cities and, as Patrick said, need a lot of these extra amenities to have the same quality of life, right? Versus in Nebraska, those are capital expenses, I guess. And yeah, I think that whole thing is is interesting I think uh I did see a lot of um people getting back to like the furniture and and sort of being comfortable working from home I did see a lot of people
没有需求的开发人员则处于非常低的档次——它应该会拉开差距，对吧。是的，是的，我完全同意。是的，我觉得特别是结合你刚才说的，如果你有一项小众技能，而且如果培养这种手艺的唯一方法，比方说，就是去这三家公司之一工作，那么这就是你的全部人才库。所以，你知道，扩展到全世界其实并不重要，因为全世界并没有接触过那三家拥有这种内置人才或其他什么的公司。对吧？所以，是的，我觉得这些人可能会过得很好。我认为那些更偏向多面手的人，我觉得那可能是一个会出现某种压榨的地方。观众实际上有一个问题，我觉得非常非常有用。我们将跳到一些
buying I actually also bought one like a like these mechanical desks that go up and down for your house and uh that was something I used a lot of at work. And I thought that it would be an insane amount of money, but it's actually, they've come down in price. You can get one at a pretty reasonable amount. And so far, I think that's been the biggest improvement in working from home for me has been getting a desk where I could stand up. Yeah, I also have a standing desk. Yeah, I bought it years ago and I haven't regretted it. Although I spend lots of time sitting at it.
观众的问题上。所以 Cheesy Taco deluxe 问，现在我们都在远程办公，入职新团队成员以及经历面试流程是什么体验？谁想先尝试回答一下？我来吧。所以，是的，我们有一个面试流程。我的意思是，我们现在使用的是 Zoom 而不是 Skype，但它往往只涉及一些 Zoom 通话。所以我们会做一些，我不知道，比如 CoderPad 之类的事情，我们会让某人在解决问题的同时把思路讲出来，就像你在白板前做的那样。我们只有几个这样的阶段。是的。然后，你知道的，会有人把笔记本电脑邮寄出去，你知道的，他们就开始了。当我刚开始在现在的工作岗位上时，我的第一天电脑还没到。所以其实我不太确定该怎么办。我联系了 IT，他们说他们把电脑寄到了我住的附近区域，但不是我确切的房子，这可不是……哦，那太离奇了。
Yeah, I think for podcasts, it's probably good to be sitting. I think the market dynamics thing is interesting. I think I saw something online that said that the market for software developers is going to get even more divided. Right. I mean, this was a theory because like if I live in Nebraska and you're trying to pay me local Nebraska wages, but I actually have a counteroffer from some other like Bay Area company, you're just going to pay me the Bay Area rate. Right. But if I if I don't, then I'll get the Nebraska wage wage and as this slowly fans out i think it will just mean that developers that are in demand get like a very high bracket and and
是的，就像那样。我不知道。就好像他们把街道上的某些数字颠倒了什么的。哦，我最终还是拿到了笔记本电脑。但第一天我就像是在说：“我来了。”他们说：“好吧，你其实什么也做不了。”所以，但我的意思是，我觉得……等等，为什么不呢？
developers that aren't are in a very low like it should it should stretch things out um yep yep yeah i totally agree yeah i think that especially with what you said earlier if you have a niche skill um and if if the only way you let's say, build that craft is to work at one of these three companies, then that's your pool of talent. And so, you know, expanding to the whole world doesn't really matter because the whole world hasn't been exposed to those three companies that have this embedded talent or whatever it is. Right. And so, yeah, I think those people could probably do well. I think the people who are more generalist, I think that might be a place where there'll be some kind of compression. There's actually a question from the audience, which I thought was really, really useful. We'll jump to some of the
你没有任何访问权限什么的吗？是的。哦，我明白了。是的，我需要工作电脑。当时，所有东西都在 VPN 后面。现在我们用 Okta，这挺不错的。哦，对，没错。但，是的，我的意思是，我觉得我们只需要
audience questions. So Cheesy Taco deluxe asks um what is it like onboarding new team members and going through the interview process uh you know now that we're all remote um who wants to take a crack at that first um i can so um yeah we have an interview process i mean we use zoom rather than skype that we're right now, but it tends to involve just some Zoom calls. And so we'll do like, I don't know, like CoderPad or something like that, where we'll have somebody work through a problem, kind of talking it out the same as you might for a whiteboard. And we have like just a couple phases of that. Yeah. And then, you know, somebody gets mailed out a laptop and, you know, they start my when I started at my current job on my first day didn't arrive. And so I wasn't really sure what to do. And I contacted the IT and they're like, they had sent it like to like the general vicinity of where I live, but not my exact house, which isn't. Oh, that's pretty bizarre.
适应。对吧。我觉得，也就是说，显然现在情况并非如此，但在后疫情时代，如果人们仍然远程工作，我觉得聚在一起依然很重要。就像，你知道，我们，你知道的，我曾在各个地方的团队工作过，但就像一个季度我们会聚在一起一次，表面上是为了做规划，但实际上就像是一起出去玩，把彼此当作三维立体的人来认识。
Yeah, like that. I don't know. It's like they transpose some numbers in the street or something. Oh, I got I got the laptop eventually. But the first day I was like, I'm here. And they're like, all right, well, you can't really do anything. So, but I mean, I think... Wait, why not?
是的，我觉得非常相似。我们有一套，我想我们用的是，我们实际上在使用一个叫做 BlueJeans 的产品，它有点像企业版的 Zoom。但基本上它是一套，你知道的，视频聊天，然后我们还使用 CoderPad，然后，哦，这里有一个关于
You didn't have any access or something? Yeah. Oh, I see. Yeah, I needed the work computer. At that time, everything was, like, behind a VPN. Now we use, like, Okta, which is pretty nice. Oh, yeah, right. But yeah, I mean, I think we just
CoderPad 的有趣背景故事，CoderPad 实际上是由一个在我们公司工作过的人创立的……他们最后……因为我们是第一批客户，我曾为一家极其巨大的公司工作。我们花了大约 1 万美元买了一个终身制的、全公司范围的 CoderPad 许可证。我们可能在上面投入了大概 20 万小时之类的时间。是的，我确信他们从我们身上赚不到什么钱。但，是的，我们非常大量地使用 CoderPad，寄出 Offer，寄出笔记本电脑，然后我们建立了一套入职文档，里面写着：“这里是你应该加入的社群，这里有一些来自某些高管的视频，他们谈论公司、谈论团队以及一切。”这似乎运作得相当不错。和你们所说的一样，我们也有，实际上，我们还没有进行面对面的活动，因为，你知道，我们都是随着新冠疫情开始居家办公的。所以我们还没有机会做到这一点。但我们确实有，每周二，我们都有一个社交时间。而且，你知道，这不是强制性的。这有点像这种奇怪的事情，对吧，我们真的很希望每个人都在场。但一旦我们强制执行，它就不再是社交活动了。它又变成了工作。所以人们来来去去。
have to adapt. Right. I think that like, I mean, obviously right now it's, it's not the case, but you know, in, in a post COVID world that people are still working remotely, I think like getting together is still important. Like, you know, we, you know, I worked on teams where we're kind of all over the place, but like once a quarter we get together, you know, ostensibly for planning, but really like just to hang out and like know each other as people who are three-dimensional. Yeah.
我们在场的人数比例相当可观。我们只是聊天或者玩游戏。我们昨天实际上玩了一个叫 Zombs Royale 的游戏，这是一个网页游戏，你可以在里面……它类似于 PUBG 或 Fortnite 或其中某个游戏，这是一个你可以作为团队建立凝聚力的方式。强迫自己抽出时间真的很不错，否则它就不会自然发生。你知道，就像我们会说：“嘿，你想出去散步吗？”但现在你做不到这一点，你真的必须强迫它发生。你必须说：“好吧，下午 2 点到 3 点，伙计们，我们去做点酷的事情吧。”这看起来很奇怪。
Yeah, I think it's very similar. We have, you know, a set of, I think we use, we actually use this product called BlueJeans, which is kind of like a Zoom type thing for enterprise. But basically it's a set of these, you know video video chats and then um we also use coder pad and then oh here's a kind of an interesting backstory behind
我的意思是，作为一个安排会议的人，开会打电子游戏感觉怪怪的。你知道，感觉就像是，好吧，他们为什么为此付给我们薪水？但我认为你需要它来维持一个健康的团队，拥有一个健康的氛围。我想这和把以前只是隐性的或自然发生的事情明确化是一样的。就像你说的，你以前会自然地和别人一起闲逛和扯淡，而现在这大大减少了。所以我们做过类似的事情。比如我们在网上玩过几次桌游，周五只花一个小时。同样的事情，你知道的，在一天快结束的时候，就像：“嘿，大家都上线来做这个吧。”而且这确实感觉有点怪，但我是那个……
coder pad is um coder pad was actually started by somebody who worked at uh our company and um they ended up because we were like the first customer, I worked for this gigantic company. And we spent something like $10,000 for a lifetime, like company-wide license for CoderPad. And we've probably put like, you know, 200,000 hours into it or something. Yeah, I'm sure they're not making any money off us. But yeah, we all see Cer pad pretty heavily mail out the offer mail out the laptop and then we we built like um a set of onboarding docs that have like here's the social groups you should join here's some videos from you know some some of the leaders just
CoderPad 呃，CoderPad 其实是由我们公司的一位前员工创立的，然后呢，因为我们算最早的客户，我当时在一家超大公司工作。我们只花了大约 10,000 美元就买断了 CoderPad 的公司级终身许可证。我们可能在上面投入了，你知道的，大概 20 万小时之类的时间。是的，我敢肯定他们从我们身上赚不到什么钱。不过是的，我们大家对 CoderPad 的使用频率非常高，寄出录用信，寄出笔记本电脑，然后我们制作了一套入职文档，里面包含诸如“以下是你应该加入的社交群组”、“这里有一些来自公司高管的视频”，主要是
talking about the company and talking about the team and everything and that seemed to work pretty well and similar to what you were saying we also have, actually, we don't have yet an in-person thing because, you know, we all started working from home with COVID. So we haven't had the chance to do that yet. But we do have, every Tuesday, we have a social hour. And, you know, it's not mandatory. It's kind of this weird thing, right, where we really want everyone to be there. But as soon as we enforce it, it's not a social thing anymore. It becomes work again. So people come and go.
谈论公司、谈论团队以及各种事情，这似乎效果相当不错。而且，和你刚才说的类似，我们也有……其实，我们目前还没有线下聚会，因为你知道的，我们都是从疫情开始时就居家办公了。所以我们还没机会那样做。不过，我们确实每周二都有一个社交时间。而且，你知道的，这不是强制的。这有点奇怪，对吧，我们真的很希望每个人都能出席。但一旦我们强制要求，它就不再是社交活动了。它又变成了工作。所以大家都是自由来去的。
We have a decent percentage of people there. And we just chat or we'll play a game. We actually played this game called Zombs Royale yesterday, which was this web game where you, it's similar to like PUBG or Fortnite or one of these games, which is something where you can kind of bond as a team. It's really good to kind of force that time because it would be emergent otherwise. You know, like we'll just say, hey, do you want to just go for a walk? But now that you can't do that, you really have to kind of force it. You have to say like, OK, 2 to 3 p.m., guys, let's go do something cool. And it seems weird.
我们有相当一部分人会去参加。我们只是闲聊，或者玩游戏。我们昨天实际上玩了一款叫 Zombs Royale 的游戏，这是一款网页游戏，你可以在里面……它类似于绝地求生（PUBG）或堡垒之夜（Fortnite）之类的游戏，这是一种能让团队凝聚在一起的方式。强行安排这种时间真的很好，因为否则它可能不会自然发生。你知道的，就像我们以前会说：“嘿，你想出去散步吗？”但现在既然你没法那样做，你真的必须强行安排。你必须说：“好吧，各位，下午 2 点到 3 点，我们去搞点好玩的。”这看起来很奇怪。
I mean, as a person who sort of set up the meeting, it felt weird to make a meeting to play video games. You know, it feels like, well, why are they paying us for this? But I think that you need it to sort of have a healthy team, have a healthy environment. I think would be the same as making things explicit, which were just implicit or emergent before. Like you were saying, you would naturally hang out with people and shoot the breeze, which goes down kind of a lot. So we've done something similar. Like we've played board games online a few times, just like one hour on Friday. The same thing, you know, kind of middle end of the day, just like, hey, everyone get on and do this. And it also does feel weird, but I'm the
我的意思是，作为一个发起这个会议的人，为了玩电子游戏而专门开个会，感觉怪怪的。你知道的，这让人觉得，嗯，为什么公司还要付钱让我们干这个？但我觉得你需要它来维持一个健康的团队，拥有一个健康的环境。我觉得这和把以前那种隐性或自然发生的事情显性化是一样的。就像你刚才说的，你以前会自然而然地和大家一起闲逛、扯淡，而现在这种情况大大减少了。所以我们也做了类似的事情。比如我们有时会在网上玩桌游，就在周五抽出一小时。同样的，你知道的，在接近下班的时候，就说：“嘿，大家都上线来玩这个吧。”这确实也感觉怪怪的，但我
same thing. I don't feel bad about it because I feel that it's important for the team to be oriented towards each other and sort of the way that would happen much more fluidly. What would you in 3D space? Maybe if we all had vr goggles it would be a different story but you know like thinking about people as more than just their comments on a code review or their status update is is really important um to being able to put yourself in their shoes and have that kind of emotional intelligence that sometimes people write about i think um you need to kind of know another person and you don't get that if you strictly just interact or at least in my opinion i find it difficult to just know that from the strict business interaction
同样道理。我对此并没有负罪感，因为我觉得团队能够相互契合、以更加自然流畅的方式进行交流非常重要。如果在三维空间里，你会怎么做？也许如果我们都戴上VR眼镜，情况就会有所不同，但你知道的，把同事不仅仅看作是代码审查中的评论或者状态更新，这对于能够设身处地为他们着想、具备那种有时人们会提及的情商来说，真的是非常重要，嗯，我觉得你需要去了解另一个人，如果你仅仅进行业务上的互动，或者至少在我看来，很难仅仅通过严格的商务互动来做到这一点。
that tends to be the default engagement model with this remote stuff yeah that is true yeah you you made me think of a couple other things so we have like like uh like you were saying we have you know join this channel join this channel um we also have like during the first week um like we'll fill up kind of like half of your first couple days with just like meetings that are just like you should say hi to this person um and say hi to this person um and then we also have a buddy program that somebody might work set up which is like they they take somebody anybody who's new gets just like paired with somebody who volunteers, who's like from a different part of the company. And they just they just meet like casually on an ongoing basis, because sometimes like I don't a problem that's not been solved by all this stuff is like like silos like if you develop social structures with your with your team like you do end up kind of not like you're not going to run into people in the kitchen
这往往是这种远程办公模式下的默认互动方式，是的，确实如此。嗯，你让我想到了其他几件事情，所以我们有，就像你刚才说的，比如“加入这个频道，加入这个频道”。我们还有，比如在第一周，我们会把你的前几天的一半时间排满各种会议，内容仅仅是“你应该和这个人打个招呼”，以及“和这个人打个招呼”。然后我们还有一个“伙伴计划”，可能会由某个人来设置，也就是把任何新入职的人与一个自愿参与的、来自公司不同部门的人配对。他们会定期进行随意的会面，因为有时我并不，所有这些东西都无法解决的一个问题是，就像各个团队之间会形成信息孤岛一样。如果你只和自己的团队建立社交结构，你最终确实不会在厨房里偶遇那些来自不同团队的人。
head or something who are on a on a different team um so that's our attempt at that but i think that's a hard problem yeah totally i've seen you know things like uh so you know we were in the office we had something called chow roulette where it would randomly pick two people who had signed up to this Chow Roulette and make them have a one-on-one lunch together. And so there were different groups. There was a Chow Roulette for engineers. There was one for salespeople. Then there was a general one if you just wanted to get matched up with anybody. And something like that, I think could could easily translate to online if i could probably be better online is probably more
或者类似的地方，而那些人在不同的团队。所以这是我们在这方面做出的尝试，但我认为这是一个难题。是的，完全如此，我见过一些这样的事情，比如，当我们在办公室的时候，我们有一个叫做“食堂轮盘（Chow Roulette）”的东西，它会随机挑选两个报名参加这个“食堂轮盘”的人，让他们一起吃一对一的午餐。所以会有不同的群组。有一个是给工程师的“食堂轮盘”。有一个是给销售人员的。然后如果随便跟任何人匹配都行的话，还有一个通用的群组。我觉得像这样的东西，可以很容易地转化到线上，而且在线上可能效果会更好，在线下可能会更尴尬。
awkward in person um you know because one person has to walk really far to get to the other person where they're eating right um um yeah and the thing you mentioned there was i went to a i had a virtual conference where um they had interesting button. You'd click this button and it was as if you ran into somebody in the hallway, like in between two conference rooms. So like, it's like while, like when one talk ended, there's about a 15 minute break. And during that break, you could click the button. And then if someone else clicked the button,
你知道的，因为一个人必须走很远的路才能走到另一个正在吃饭的人那里，对吧。嗯，你刚才提到的一件事是，我参加过一个虚拟会议，他们有一个很有意思的按钮。你点击这个按钮，就好像你在走廊里偶遇了某人一样，比如在两个会议室之间。所以，就好像在，当一个演讲结束时，大约有15分钟的休息时间。在那个休息时间，你可以点击这个按钮。然后如果其他人也点击了这个按钮，
you would run into each other and it would just basically be like a one-on-one chat. And then after a minute or so, you would hang up and you could try it again. I didn't try it, but things like this, I think, are starting to get at that kind of just, you know, emergent conversation that happens in real life. It seems hard because it seems like forced, where like you know a lot of this stuff in person happens very naturally um but there is a a slack bot i don't know if you guys use slack but called like coffee i think it's called like coffee time and it's like people join this channel and then randomly i think once a week it like the bot will like ping you and somebody else and say like you guys should meet um and have coffee
你们就会偶遇，基本上就像是一对一的聊天。然后大约一分钟左右后，你就可以挂断并再次尝试。我没有尝试过这种，但我觉得类似这样的功能，开始触及到那种现实生活中才会发生的、自然浮现的对话。这看起来很难，因为它感觉很生硬，你知道现实生活中的很多这类事情发生得非常自然。不过，有一个Slack机器人，我不知道你们用不用Slack，它叫“咖啡时间”之类的，就是人们加入这个频道，然后随机地，我想大概一周一次，这个机器人会发消息@你和另一个人，说“你们应该见个面，喝杯咖啡”。
oh it's cool it's sort of uh it's like the minimum viable product version of uh your your chat roulette or whatever yeah right cool uh someone asked um they said basically um actually i get the person's name so this is gaython on on Twitter. Gaethon said basically they work from home and they also that's sort of their leisure space. So it could be playing video games, watching TV. And so since they do both in the same space, when they're having sort of a bad day at work, they also don't want to have fun anymore because it's kind of like tainted. Right. And so, you know, one way to solve that is, you know, if you have a big enough place then you could just subdivide right but assuming that that for folks who are as patrick said you know kind of in the apartment setting um you know and they can only have one place to do work and to have fun um you know what are some tips we could give them to make that all
哦，这挺酷的，这有点像是你们那个聊天轮盘什么的“最小可行性产品”版本，对吧。酷，有人提问了，他们基本上说，实际上我记得那个人的名字，这是Twitter上的盖顿（Gaethon）。盖顿说，他们基本上是在家里工作，而且这也是他们的休闲空间。比如玩电子游戏、看电视。所以既然他们在这个相同的空间里做这两件事，当他们在工作中遇到糟糕的一天时，他们也不想再玩乐了，因为这感觉有点被污染了。对吧。所以，你知道，解决这个问题的一个方法是，如果你有一个足够大的地方，那么你就可以进行功能分区。但假设对于像帕特里克（Patrick）所说的那样，住在公寓里的人来说，你知道的，他们只能有一个地方来工作和娱乐，你知道的，我们可以给他们什么建议来让这一切
easier so i worked with somebody before who like went for a walk like before they started their day and then after like they literally commuted like back to their house um oh that's a good idea i love that idea maybe it can mentally uh you know like change the scenery and have you reset um yeah you got to find some way to kind of like yeah to to keep things like to block things out, I guess. But that's the best one. Yeah, just bootstrapping off that. When I have one on one meetings, I'll actually take a lot of those. I'll actually walk for a lot of those. So if I'm having a one on one meeting that's pretty casual with somebody that I meet with every week, where I
变得更容易呢？所以我以前共事过一个人，他在一天开始之前会去散步，然后在结束之后也去——他字面意义上就是“通勤”回自己的家。哦，是个好主意，我很喜欢这个主意。也许它能在精神上，你知道的，改变一下风景，让你重置一下。是的，你得找到某种方法来，你知道的，把事情隔离开来，我猜。但这是最好的一个办法。是的，顺着这个思路。当我开一对一会议时，其实我很多时候都会这么做。我实际上会边走边开很多这样的会。所以如果我跟一个每周都见的、关系比较随意的同事开一对一会议，我不怎么需要做大量笔记之类的。
don't really expect them any take a lot of notes or something. You know, I'll keep my phone in my pocket. I'll have the headphones on and I'll just go for a walk around the neighborhood. And yeah, after a few weeks of that, I start just disliking all of my neighbors. No, but I think anytime you can get some exercise and kind of enjoy nature and stuff, I think that is one really good way to sort of recreate that. Because, I mean, when I did have these same meetings in person, that is what we did. We would go for a walk, sometimes even walk outside for a bit.
你知道的，我会把手机放在口袋里，戴上耳机，然后在社区周围散步。是的，几个星期这样下来，我开始变得讨厌所有的邻居了。开玩笑的。不过我觉得，只要你能做点运动、享受大自然之类的，我认为这真的是重现那种状态的一个好方法。因为，当我在现实中开同样的会议时，我们就是这么做的。我们会去散步，有时甚至会去外面走一会儿。
And so now it's even easier to do stuff like that. This is not my situation, so just making up ideas but i wonder too if you took it extreme so not only if you sort of walked to your house to start your work and then walked at the end of the day but you could kind of go half a step further and get those they have those hue light bulbs you know that change color temperature so like i notice i have my window open at my house so my room is lit sort of naturally but when I'm at work it's like I can't even see a window like it's just all harsh artificial lighting and that sounds kind of goofy but if you even like changed more of your space to like change scenes and if you had like a
所以现在做这种事甚至更容易了。这不是我的处境，所以我只是在瞎编一些想法。不过我在想，如果你把它推到极端，不仅在开始工作时走到你的家（当作通勤），在一天结束时也去散步，而且你还可以再进一步，去买那种飞利浦Hue智能灯泡，你知道的，那种可以改变色温的灯泡。我注意到我家里窗户开着，所以我的房间有自然光照进来，但当我工作时，感觉甚至看不到窗户——全都是刺眼的、人工的照明。这听起来有点傻，但如果你甚至把你的更多空间通过改变场景来布置，如果你在工作时用非常酷炫的冷蓝色，然后在一天结束时把它变成较暖的蓝色，我是说，我不知道，我没试过这个，但这只是增加了一种可能性：你可能在同一个空间里，但如果你把办公桌往右挪一英尺并改变颜色，我是说，你可以说服自己：“哦，是的，这完全不同了。”而且我认为，是的，这是心理作用，是非常深层的心理作用，所以，是的，完全有用。
very you know cool blue while you were working and then changed it to a warmer blue sort of at the end of the day I mean I don't know I've not tried that but it's just sort of adding to the you may be in the same space but if you move your desk a foot to the right and change the color and i mean you can kind of convince yourself that oh yeah no this is completely different uh and i think yeah i mean it's psychological it's like deep psychological so yeah yeah totally works i think you just caused amazon to run out of stock of hue light bulbs i think it's a great idea yeah when i when i first worked at home in my apartment and i had like a computer and a desk that i that i used for like casual stuff like gaming or whatever and i got an identical desk and i put them like on opposite walls um and i just like i didn't have
我觉得你刚刚让亚马逊的Hue智能灯泡卖断货了。我觉得这是个好主意。是的，当我第一次在公寓里在家办公时，我有一台电脑和一张桌子，我用它来做一些随意的休闲事情，比如打游戏什么的。然后我弄了一张一模一样的桌子，把它们放在相对的墙上。我只是，我没有遇到完全一模一样的问题，但我知道，如果我面向这个方向，那就是工作；如果我面向另一个方向，那就是，我是说，我现在不做那么极端的区分了，但我想你得自己找到如何把事情分开的方法。是的，完全说得通。是的，我觉得，你知道的，有一件一直很有挑战性的事情是，而且，实际上，能够听听你的看法会很棒，亚当（Adam）。所以，对我自己以及可能帕特里克来说，我们基本上是因为新冠疫情（COVID）被迫在家办公的。
this exact same problem but i knew like if i was facing one way that was like work and if i was facing the other way it was uh i mean i don't i now i don't do anything that severe but i guess you got to find how to separate things yourself yeah totally makes sense yeah i think um um you know one thing that's been really challenging is is you know and and uh actually yeah it'd be great to get your take on this, Adam. So, you know, for myself and probably Patrick, like we were basically forced to work from home because of COVID. And so what that meant is, you know, day one of working from home was also day one of school shutting down, daycare shutting down, you know, and all of our, uh, uh, kids like being in our responsibility. And so it's just like an
这意味着，在家办公的第一天也是学校关闭、日托中心关闭的第一天，你知道的，我们所有的，呃，孩子们都需要我们来照顾。所以这就像是一个巨大的冲击。老实说，我不知道帕特里克怎么想，但我真的，我刚才提到的那个星期三的事我都不算数，因为那是一周里的一天。所以你可以围绕它来规划其他所有事情。但老实说，我真的不知道在没有所有这些其他外部因素的情况下，全职在家办公是什么感觉，对吧？所以，也许我们可以通过这种方式来进行逆向工程，那就是让你稍微谈谈，疫情前和疫情后有什么不同？因为你一直都在家办公。
enormous shock. And so I honestly, I don't, I don't know about Patrick, but I don't really, you know, I don't count the Wednesday thing that I mentioned earlier, because it's one day a week. So you kind of plan everything else around it. But I honestly don't really know what it's like to work from home full time without like all of these other you know externalities right and so one way that maybe we could sort of like reverse engineer this is is for you to talk a little bit about you know what was it like pre versus post covid uh because you've been working from home the whole time yeah i mean yeah i'm trying to think. So I've found like, I could tell you, like, just at a at a at a gut, like psychological level that like, I feel more like closer to burnout lately with the whole COVID situation, even though like, not a lot of my work life has changed, right? Like I, I worked here where you see me now, you know, a year ago, and I still do now. But, but now I do feel a bit boxed in um you know like so i think you know it's because you can't you it's not just that i'm here for work it's that i'm here for
是的，我是说，我在想。我发现，我可以告诉你，就像在直觉或心理层面上，我最近因为整个新冠疫情的情况，感觉自己更接近职业倦怠了，尽管我的工作生活其实没怎么变，对吧？比如，我现在就在你看到我的这个地方工作，一年前也是，现在还是。但是，现在我确实觉得自己有点被禁锢住了，你知道的，所以我认为，你知道的，这是因为你不能——不仅是因为我为了工作才呆在这里，而是因为我为了所有事情都得呆在这里，
everything right and maybe that that goes to that person's uh question about about kind of feeling kind of stuck in their bad day um so i think that these circumstances are not the ideal uh work from home circumstances um i i don't have any like i don't have any specifics though yeah i mean one thing i i noticed as well is is um and we talked about this in the past episode with max is um i feel this like it's very kind of um um like this bipolar like this up like very much like ups and downs and i think it's related to the fact that, and this gets to what the person was asking too. And the question is that you're in the same room for kind of everything. And so it just tends to, yeah, I think getting to what you were saying too, Adam, is like,
对吧？也许这就呼应了那个人关于“感觉自己被困在糟糕的一天里”的问题。所以我认为这些环境并不是理想的居家办公环境。不过我也没有什么具体的细节。嗯，我注意到的另一件事是，我们在过去的节目中跟马克斯（Max）讨论过，我有一种感觉，这非常像，呃，就像这种双相情感障碍一样的起伏跌宕，我认为这与以下事实有关，这也呼应了那个提问者的问题。问题在于你在同一个房间里做所有的事情。所以它往往会，是的，我觉得这也契合了你刚才说的，亚当，
I feel like I'm kind of always plugged in because I'm always, you know, 10 feet away from work. And so if someone sends me a work email, I'm just much more likely to reply at the dinner table versus before, you know, there's a, there's kind of that, that mental barrier. And, and now I think with the COVID situation, you know, the reality is like, you know, I, at least personally, like, and probably feel you might feel the same way, Patrick's like, I can't give it a hundred percent when there are so many people, so much social infrastructure that I depend on that isn't there right now. And so when you combine not like a clear barrier between work and home with the fact that like, you know, you can't contribute as much as you did when everything else was open,
我觉得我好像总是处于“在线”状态，因为我离工作地点总是只有十英尺远。所以如果有人给我发一封工作邮件，我在餐桌上回复的可能性要大得多，而在以前，你知道的，有一种心理屏障。而现在，我认为由于新冠疫情的情况，现实情况是，你知道的，至少就我个人而言，可能帕特里克你也有同感，当有这么多我所依赖却不在身边的社会基础设施时，我无法做到百分之百投入。所以，当你把“工作与家庭之间没有清晰的界限”这一点，与“你无法像一切都开放时那样做出那么多贡献”结合起来时，
I think it gives you kind of this ups and downs where you feel like, oh, I'm not doing enough, I'm not doing enough. And then after you work for a day, you feel really accomplished. And then it kind of goes back. Yeah, I like so I'm on my team, like we were all kind of distributed, but but some people did work in an office. But, you know, many people didn't like before COVID. Now everybody's at home. The the people who have had the most challenge would be the people who have kids who are now home all the time. Like, you know, they, you know, like maybe they worked from home before, but they had daycare and now they have their kid there. It seems like everybody's adapted. But yeah, maybe it's just slowly wearing them down. I don't know. Somebody told me that they had gotten these
我认为它会给你带来这种起伏感，你会觉得自己“哦，我做得不够，我做得不够”。然后当你工作了一天之后，你会觉得很有成就感。然后这种感觉又会循环回去。是的，我就像，在我的团队里，我们都是分散办公的，但有些人确实在办公室工作。不过，你知道，在疫情之前，很多人并不在办公室工作。现在每个人都在家里。遇到最大挑战的人，往往是那些家里有孩子、现在孩子整天都在家里的员工。就像，你知道，他们可能以前也居家办公，但他们有日托服务，而现在他们的孩子就在身边。似乎每个人都在适应。但是，是的，也许这正在慢慢地把他们消磨殆尽，我不知道。有人告诉我，他们买了一些儿童用的沙漏，三种不同的规格：一个是一小时的，一个是30分钟的，还有一个是15分钟的。然后当他们在开会时，他们会把沙漏放在桌上并翻转过来。他们教会自己的孩子，你知道的，当沙漏里的沙子漏完时，就是你可以跟我说话的时候。所以，我是说，我想人们正在针对“居家办公是如何运作的”进行一定程度的培训。
like children's like sand timers, like three different ones, like one that was like an hour and one that was 30 minutes, one that was 15 minutes. And then when they're in a meeting, they like put it on their desk and turn it. And then they taught their kid that like, you know, when it runs out of sand, that's when you can talk to me. So, I mean, I guess there's a certain amount of training that people are doing about about how how working from home works um i think even if you didn't have these current circumstances and you worked from home um you know and it's summertime and your kids are around like there is a certain type of work that needs to be done probably to establish
我觉得，即使你没有这些当前的特殊情况，只是在夏天居家办公，孩子们都在周围，为了建立界限，可能也需要做一定类型的工作，比如“我现在很忙”之类的。我没有任何孩子，我只有猫，我可以把门关上。哦，帕特里克，你静音了。哦，你能听见吗？哦，现在能听见了。我刚才想说，呃，你就不能把门关上吗？不，开玩笑的，别。是的，我们有两只猫现在正在砰砰砸门，不过没关系。是的，我是说，我觉得，我觉得这是对的。我猜这就引出了，你知道的，每个人都试图在预测未来会是什么样子的思维螺旋中寻找答案。但我认为，人们拿当前或夏天的状态与秋天作对比并进行预测，未必是正确的模型，因为把你的孩子留在家里，或者
barriers like you know right now i'm busy and and things like that i don't have any i don't have any children i just have cats and i can just close the door so oh patrick you went on mute oh can you hear me oh now we can hear you yeah i was like uh can you just not shut the door no i'm just kidding don't yeah we got i got two banging at the door right now but it's totally fine yeah i mean i think, I think that's right. I guess that goes to, you know, everyone tries to spiral in projecting what the future will look like. But I think people taking what it's like right now or in the summertime versus the fall and projecting it out isn't necessarily the right model because having your kids at home or
我的意思是，甚至比那更糟，对吧？在学年期间，我们家就是这样，不仅孩子们在家，他们还需要上学，这就变成了“等等，我既要管你上学，又要忙我自己的工作”。幸运的是，你知道的，我觉得我非常幸运和特权，这可能也适用于你们，那就是我的工作非常通情达理，他们会说：“嘿，我们知道这是个特殊情况，我们稍微降低一点期望，你知道的，基本上尽力而行就行了。”并且，你知道的，我觉得我仍然能够做到并负责任地对待这一点。但是，是的，我是说，如果人们从现在汲取经验并将它们向前推断，
I mean, it's even worse than that, right? During the school year, which was the case with us, is like not only were the kids home, but they needed to do their school and it's like yeah wait a minute like i'm supposed to be doing your school and my work and thankfully you know like i think i'm very lucky and privileged and probably um might apply to you guys as well but like my work is very understanding and just saying like hey like we know this is a thing like we we're lowering sort of expectations a little like you know try the best you can basically um and you know i i feel like i was still able to do and treat that responsibly but yeah i mean i think people taking learnings from now and projecting them forward
如果没有全球大流行病，我们可能无法像平时那样维持这种可持续性。而且情况甚至远不止于此——人们的假期被取消了，春假被取消了，虽然夏天没有被取消，但通常人们会期待旅行、规划旅行、期待家人来访，而所有这些都没有发生，或者说发生得少得多。所以我觉得“职业倦怠”这件事对人们来说风险极高。我认为你必须确保自我监控，而我觉得人们对自己个人状态的感知能力各有不同，并需要对此进行内省。但我的意思是，非常可能的是，如果像这样——我是说，这个问题在8月、9月、10月是不会解决的，所以你得
is not we're not able to sort of make it as sustainable as you might otherwise if there wasn't a global pandemic you know and it's it's more so even than that like people's vacations got canceled people's spring breaks got canceled summer hasn't been canceled but normally people would be looking forward to traveling and planning that traveling and family coming to visit and like none of that is going on or a lot less of it is going on and so i the burnout thing i think is super risky for people like i think you have to make sure to monitor yourself which i think people are of differing degrees of ability to tell like how their personal state is and just being introspective about that um but i mean i think it's very probable that if you like i mean this is not going to be fixed by august september october so you're
谈到从3月到10月，大概有七个月的时间。如果你一直没有去度假、没有进行“宅度假（staycation）”、没有做任何你平时会做的事情——比如请上一天假、几天假或一周的假。是的，我觉得人们会产生工作疲劳和挫折感，并把它归咎于某些可能有些偏差的事情上。这真是个极好的观点，对吧？就像，我记得曾经有一段时间，工作正处于攻坚期，我没有计划假期，也没有意识到自己已经精疲力竭了，因为我们刚刚度过了，你知道的，我们刚刚度过了正常的假期。当时，我妻子实际上在一家邮轮公司工作，所以他们在特定节奏下会为员工提供优惠，因此我们基本上总是把假期给我们规划好了。
going to talk about march to october there's like seven months. And if you've not gone on vacation or taken a staycation or done something, you normally would have taken a day, a couple of days, a week of vacation. Yeah. I think people are going to get a work fatigue and frustration and associate it to something that might be slightly misdirected. That is such a good point, right? Like, I remember there was a time when there was sort of a crunch time at work and I didn't and we didn't plan a vacation and not really realizing that I was burnt out because I we had just had, you know, we just had kind of regular vacations. At the time, my wife was actually working for a cruise line and so they would have deals for the employees at a certain cadence and so we would always we always kind of just had basically the
所以并不那么显而易见，比如“哦，我竟然已经快一年没休假了，我已经完全精疲力竭了”。所以，是的，我觉得这是一个非常棒的观点：在疫情期间，没有人真的想去度假，因为你能干嘛呢？你只能在社区周围散步，或者很少有营业的场所。但另一方面，是的，很多人可能会精疲力竭，
vacations planned for us and so it wasn't kind of obvious that like oh like I hadn't taken a vacation in in you know almost a year and I'm totally burnt out and so yeah I think it's such a good point like no one really wants to take a vacation during a pandemic because what do you do? You just walk around your neighborhood or there's very few things that are open. But then on the flip side, yeah, a lot of people will probably get burnt out
甚至可能都不知道原因。是的，我觉得，对，去过个“宅度假”吧！放几天假，我不知道，把电脑放到别的地方去，读本书什么的。如果可以的话，每天都出门走走。是的，比如有一本关于远程办公的书，作者是DHH，也就是搞Rails的那个人。我记得，关于这本书我几乎什么都没记住，除了他说过的一点：你应该根据自己觉得今天是不是投入了美好的一天的工作来评价自己，而不应该真正去追踪
and maybe not even know why. Yeah, I think like, yeah, take a staycation, right? Like take some time off and I don't know, put your computers in somewhere else and read a book or something. And just, like, get out of the house every day if you can. Yeah, like, there's a book about working remotely from DHH, the Rails guy. And I remember, like, one, I remember very little of the book except that he said that, like, you should judge yourself on yourself on whether like it seemed like you put in a good day of work like that you shouldn't really keep track
你工作了多少个小时，或者这个那个。你懂的，如果你在世上有过经验，并且你知道“嘿，我今天解决了一些问题，这是美好的一天的工作”，这就足够了，别太折磨自己了。也许你甚至需要把这个标准再调低一点，对吧？如果你家里有孩子或其他限制条件，也许，如果你接近度过了一个不错的工作日，那就拍拍自己的背鼓励一下自己，别太苛求自己、别对自己太严厉。是的，完全说得通。有人问——我觉得我们已经讨论过这个了，但是，呃——鲁比克之鞋（Rubik's shoe），我不知道这是否有意双关了魔方（Rubik's cube），
of like how much hours you did or or this or that you're like you know if if you have experience like in the world and and you know like hey you know i solved some things today this was a good day's work like that's good enough like don't be beat yourself up maybe you need to even turn that down even more right like if you have kids at home or other constraints like maybe you know if if you got close to a good day's work like pat yourself on the back don't beat yourself up and be hard on yourself yeah totally makes sense um someone asked and i think we covered this but but uh but Rubik's shoe, which I don't know if that's intentionally a pun on Rubik's cube,
还是说这只是脑海中浮现的第一个词，但不管怎样，这名字太酷了。鲁比克之鞋基本上是在问，你知道的，是什么阻止了我们的雇主，是什么阻止了工资出现竞次（race to the bottom），对吧？我想，你知道的，工资竞次，并且我认为我们已经讨论过这个了。你知道，我确实认为可能会出现某种程度的工资萧条，但话说回来，很多工作都非常小众。这其实引出了另一个半吐槽的话题，那就是每个人都是软件工程师，但其中的学科太多了。
or if that's just, you know, the first thing that came to mind, but either way, that's an awesome name, Rubik's shoe, basically asking, you know, what prevents our employers from, you know, what prevents wages from, you know, a race to the bottom, right? And I think, you know, a race to the bottom right and i think you know we covered that um you know i do think that there will probably be some kind of wage depression um but again like uh a lot of jobs are really niche and this actually gets to a another kind of semi rant which is which is everyone is is software engineer but there's so many disciplines in there. And so there's so many different specialities. You know, like we talked to Guillermo Ranch, right?
所以有这么多的不同专业领域。你知道的，就像我们和吉列尔莫·劳奇（Guillermo Rauch）交谈过一样，对吧？他当时在谈论，那个叫什么来着？Next.js，我想。但基本上它是一个建立在React之上的框架。是的，我很确定是Next.js。你可以在这方面事实核查我。但是，你知道的，那种非凡的深度、理解力，以及了解历史、了解事情为什么会以那种方式运作以及其起源是什么样的能力。所以，你知道，无论你是在做前端、应用开发、后端开发，无论你是在做人工智能相关的东西，还是在做嵌入式开发，你总是会陷入某种你需要成为专家的领域。所以我不大期望这种
And he was talking about, what was it called? Next.js, I think. But basically it was a framework built on top of React. And yeah, I think pretty sure it's Next.js. You could fact check me on that. But, you know, and just extraordinary levels of depth and understanding and knowing the history and why things work the way they did and what that genesis is like. So, you know, I think whether you're doing front end, whether you're doing app development, backend development, whether you're doing AI stuff, whether you're doing embedded, you're always falling into where they're doing embedded you're always falling into some type of craft that you're becoming an expert in and so i don't really expect um this
工资萧条会像人们说的那样严重。我认为这是一个渐进的过程。我认为，你知道，是的，对于很多人来说，生活成本会显著下降，这会有所帮助。我以积极的眼光来看待这件事。就像，我认为我们可以为全世界的人注入活力，你知道的，那里有很多被固定在一个地方的人，你知道，要么是因为他们的家人在那里，有太多不同的原因，对吧？所以我们可以让所有这些人参与进来。所以我认为这里面有很大的潜力。是的。而且我预计，我不知道你们怎么看——你们对它的看法可能比我更准确——但我预计一些目前正在拥抱远程劳动力的公司会在这上面遭遇失败。因为我认为，这并不是说它对每一家公司都必然会成功。我认为这可能比想象的更难。
sort of like uh wage oppression to be as severe as people are are saying i think that it'll be a gradual thing i think that you know yeah i think for a lot of people, the cost of living will go down significantly. And so that will help. And I look at it in a positive way. Like, I think we could sort of like energize, you know, people all over the world, you know, where there's a lot of folks who are anchored to a place, you know, either because, you know, their family is there. There's so many different reasons, right? And so we can place, you know, either because, you know, their family is there. There's so many different reasons, right? And so we can engage, you know, all of these folks. And so I think that there's a lot of potential there. Yeah. And I expect, I don't know what you guys, you guys
是的，所以你认为是什么会导致人们失败呢？如果事情重新开放，我们允许人们在任何地方工作，但所有重要的人都在这栋大楼里、在这个特定的地方。我真的不确定这会成功。我认为远程办公有一种失败模式：你有一个团队，除了一个人在别的地方。
probably have a better, more accurate take on it, but I expect some places that are embracing the remote workforce right now will fail at it. Like, I think it's not a given that it's going to work out for every place. I think it's probably harder than it's. Yeah. Yeah. So what do you think is going to cause people to fail? So if things open back up and we allow people to work wherever, but everybody important is in this building, in this particular place. I'm not really sure that that's going to be successful. I think there's a failure mode for remote where you have a team except one guy. He's somewhere else.
然后他在某种程度上并不是团队的真正一员，这并不是任何人的错，只是，你知道的。所以我认为，这其实只是一种文化变革，你知道的。如果公司里的每个人都分布在各地，并以异步的方式进行沟通，而你不需要非得坐在现场，我认为这真的可以运作得很好。但如果你拘泥于传统的结构，而每个人都在一个特定的地方，这就不会取得太大的成功。是的，这说得通。
And then he's not really a true member of the team to a certain extent out of nobody's fault but just um you know so i i think um like it's really just a culture change i think um you know that like if if the if everybody in the company is working distributed and kind of communicating in ways that are async and you don't have to be right there. I think it can really work great. But if you're kind of stuck with your traditional structures and everybody's in a certain place, it's not really going to be that successful. Yeah, that makes sense.
是的，我在想软件开发的沟通是不是一个充满机遇的领域。想象一下某种软件合同之类的东西，上面写着：“看，我要构建这种系统。”我的意思是你也许可以称之为文档，或者在写代码之前编写文档，对吧？但也许，你知道的，我们能以某种方式让这个过程更加顺畅无阻。
Yeah, I'm wondering if software development communication is an area of opportunity. Imagine a software contract type of thing saying, look, I'm going to build this kind of system. I mean, I guess you could call that documentation or documenting before you write the code, right? But maybe like, you know, we somehow make that more frictionless.
我是说，我也有这个问题。我的确是在写代码的同时写文档。但我觉得，如果你要建立这样一个系统，你要宣称你要构建某些东西，而其他人要使用它，除非你无法按顺序推进，否则你必须能够并行工作。所以，你知道，目前这主要还是靠谷歌文档（Google Docs）。我们会写一个包含一些想法的谷歌文档，发出去，然后大家会给我们反馈。
I mean, I'm guilty of it. I mean, I'm definitely documenting as I'm writing the code. But I think if you're going to have a system like this where you're going to say you're going to build something and someone else is going to use it, you know, unless you can't just move sequentially, you have to be able to work in parallel. And so, you know, right now it's mostly just Google Docs. So we'll write a Google Doc just with some ideas. We'll send it out. People will give us feedback.
但也许需要更正式一点的东西，你可以，我猜如果你只是在谈论C++，你可以编写头文件并用Doxygen生成文档，这样人们就会知道该期待什么。但这只是为了让工程师之间更顺畅地沟通的一种方式，因为我认为这是对远程工作最大的批评。人们会说：“看，我有这个后端，我有这个正在制作的应用，我要做下一个TikTok，所以它必须明天就发布，因为昨天TikTok刚在印度被禁了。”
But maybe something more formal where you could, I guess if you're just talking about C++, you could write the header files and doxygen them, and then people will kind of know what to expect. But just some way for engineers to communicate more fluidly, because I think that is the number one criticism of remote work is people say look i have this back end i have this app i'm making you know the next tiktok and so it needs to be out tomorrow because tiktok was just banned in india yesterday
所以我的应用必须在明天发布，因此，你知道的，这只有在整个团队都在现场、应用开发者可以看着后端开发者的肩膀并看到函数调用时才行得通，对吧？我觉得，这些其实只是优秀的工程实践，可能会被大家更加分散办公这一趋势所推动，对吧？通常情况下，关于你的设计，唯一重要的就是API，也就是它呈现的表面。我的意思，这也许是个极端的看法，但思考这些API并在它们上面达成一致——如果两个团队必须就某事进行沟通，让我们就这个API是什么达成一致，至于其他的我其实不太关心。所以如果是团队之间，我觉得，是的，就像你说的，明确你的API，头文件或别的什么。我们在GraphQL上取得了成功，
and so my app needs to come out tomorrow and so you know it only works if the whole team is right there and uh the the the app developer can look over the backend developer's shoulder and see the function call, right? I think, like, these are just good engineering practices that might get pushed by people being more distributed, right? Like, oftentimes, like, all that matters about your design is, like, the API, like, the surface it presents. I mean, maybe that's an extreme take right but thinking about those apis and agreeing on them like if you got if two teams have to communicate about something like let's let's agree on what this api is and um like i don't really care about the rest um so if it's teams i think yeah just be explicit about your apis like you said header files or whatever Like we've had success with like GraphQL
因为GraphQL有一个模式（schema）。所以你其实是在沟通：“嘿，一切看起来都是这样的，而且它有一定的灵活性，所以他们可以发出一些不同的请求。”是的，我不知道。是的，我觉得你是对的。我认为这会迫使工程师们做好工作。
because GraphQL has like a schema. So you're kind of communicating like, hey, everything looks like this and it's a bit flexible so they can kind of make some different requests. Yeah, I don't know. Yeah, I think you're right. I think it will force engineers to do a good job.
我的意思是，这并不是一件坏事。我知道我们的很多代码都在公司内部，很多代码并没有得到很好的记录。而且我认为，这与“由坐在一起的团队快速完成的事情”以及“没有被记录好的事情”之间，有着近乎完美的正相关关系，对吧？因为如果你是分布式办公，你根本承担不起那样做的后果。所以，甚至在我们真正远程办公之前，我们显然就已经有多个办公室了。因此，跨多个办公室共同完成的事情往往质量更好，但速度也更慢。所以也许这种“这就像是10倍效能工程师的神话”的观点，现在我们有了“项目在一周内完成的神话”，其负面影响是——我们刚刚又增加了一个负面影响，那就是它不支持远程工作。但这种做法的负面影响太极端了，以至于我们不得不接受这一点：让我们把它变成两周、三周、四周，并在第一版中真正保证高质量。
I mean, which is, you know, not a bad thing. I know that a lot of our code is just in the company, a lot of our code is not documented very well. And I think it's almost perfectly correlated between things which were done quickly by teams that all sat next to each other, and things are not documented well, right? Because you just can't afford to do that if you're distributed. So even in cases where before we were really had remote work, we still obviously had multiple offices. And so things that were done jointly across multiple offices just tended to be better quality, but also slower. And so maybe this idea that it's almost like the 10x engineer myth. Maybe now we have the project done in a week myth where the downsides of that, now we just added another downside, which is that it doesn't support remote work. But the downsides of that are so extreme that we'll have to just accept that let's just make this two weeks, three weeks, four weeks and actually have good quality on version one yeah i feel like within a team like you should be able to talk it out like even if you're if you're remote um so yeah i don't know like like the place that i've seen um people
是的，我觉得在团队内部，你应该能够把事情商量好，即使你是远程办公。所以，是的，我不知道，就像我看到人们远程办公失败的例子是：如果有人独自跑去构建了某些东西，然后说“看，做好了”，接着其他人说“这不符合我的期望”。我的意思，这在远程办公中可能更容易发生，但这并不是必然的——你完全可以把事情商量好。它不一定非要是长篇大论的文档。就像我以前在构建某些东西之前，有时会在Slack频道里说：“好吧，我有这个工单要做这个功能，我的想法是这样的”，然后大家就会知道，人们会给我提供反馈。我之所以吸取到这一点，是因为经历过相反的情况：我提交了一个PR（Pull Request），然后大家
working remotely fail is like yeah if somebody just goes off and like build something and then they're like here it is um and then other people are like that's not my expectations i mean that's probably more likely to happen with working remotely but it doesn't have to right like you can just talk things out um it doesn't have to be extensive documentation like i've like sometimes before building something just in the slack channel been like okay so i have this ticket to do this thing here's what i'm thinking and then people are know, people will provide me feedback. And like, I learned this because of the reverse scenario where like I put up a PR and then people
把它批得体无完肤。所以我吸取了教训，心想：“好吧，在我开始构建之前，我们先来讨论一下方法。”所以，人们即使不在同一个房间里，也依然可以沟通。是的，完全正确。是的，我的意思是，如果你看看那些把远程办公做得很成功的组织，或者至少是那些会采用这种模式的组织，我认为销售部门一直以来几乎在所有中大型公司里都是分布式销售团队。而且，你知道，我认为这有巨大的优势。你知道，我认为，根据产品的不同，但几乎每一个产品，甚至从工程的角度来看，都可以受益于一种超本地化的视角或镜头来审视该产品。类似于，你知道的，在迪拜的销售团队
like it just gets torn to shreds. Right. So I'm like, okay, before I start building this, let's talk about the approach. Yeah. Yeah. So, I mean, people can still talk even if we're not all in the same room. Yeah. Yeah. Totally true. Yeah. I mean, I think, you know, if you look at organizations that do this well, or at least maybe organizations that do this at all, I think sales is consistently almost every medium to large size company has a distributed sales team. And, you know, I think that that think that there's huge advantages to that. You know, I think that, you know, depending on the product, but almost every product, you know, even from an engineering standpoint could benefit from, you know, a hyperlocal view or lens through which to look at that product. Similar to how, you know, the sales team
和在阿肯色州的销售团队可能并不是完全以相同的方式运作的。因此，这种稳健性和健康度会让整个系统更加健康，对吧？所以我觉得从工程的角度来看，某种特许经营模式（franchise-type model）可能会非常强大。不过说实话，说到帕特里克，我们很久以前工作过的一个地方，我不知道你们团队有没有这个，但我们确实有一些身处美国其他地方的QA（测试）人员。他们基本上会运行我们的单元测试，比如做代码覆盖率测试、寻找开发中的问题或错误。但实际上，他们与核心工程团队是完全脱节的。所以基本上，我们会收到这些人的随机邮件，上面写着：
in Dubai and the sales team in Arkansas probably don't operate exactly the same way. And so there's a robustness and a health that makes the system more healthy, right? So I think from an engineering standpoint, some type of franchise-type model could be really powerful. But actually, to Patrick, a place we used to work a long time ago, I don't know if your team had this, but we actually had some QA folks who were in another part of the US. And they would basically run our unit tests, like do code coverage, look for kind of problems, like errors in the development. But actually, they were totally disconnected from the core engineering team. So basically, we would get random emails from these folks saying,
“嘿，我们发现了一些问题”，或者“嘿，你可能想在这里多加一些测试”。但他们就像是一个独立的、不相交的组织。事后看来，这其实是一种很强大的模式，因为它是完全可扩展的。我不知道，你在你待过的任何团队里有过这种经历吗？没有，我没有。但是，是的，我能理解你说的它为什么强大。不过我的意思，这确实增加了管理开销。但，是的，我的意思，我认为这是分离团队部分职能并获得模块化和定义良好接口的优势，与获得“在没有那种硬边界的两个团队之间实现更快速迭代”的红利之间的一种权衡。我认为这只是一个经典的问题，人们必须在其中来回权衡。
hey, we found some issue, or hey, you might want to put some more tests here. But they were kind of like this separate, you know, disjoint org. And in hindsight, it's kind of like a powerful model because it's totally scalable. I don't know if, did you have that on any of the teams you were on or no? No, I didn't have that. But I, yeah, I can see how you're saying it's powerful. But I mean, it does increase overhead. But yeah, I mean, I think that's a give and take between separating parts of your team and gaining an advantage of sort of modularity and a defined interface. And then gaining the bonus of like more rapid iteration between two teams that don't have
是的，这说得通。是的，听起来我最初的想法是，我希望人们离我更近一点，对吧？我希望他们与我紧密合作，而不是完全分离开来。但我认为这完全是可能的。我不知道，我觉得当你远程办公时，你依然可以拥有紧密的小团队，我认为这是可行的。我认为团队与团队之间的协作可能会更复杂一些。是的，我觉得，你知道的，你说得完全对。我觉得这是一种划分工作的奇怪方式。
a hard boundary like that. And I think that's just like a classic problem that people have to kind of move back and forth on. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, it sounds like my initial thoughts is it sounds I would want the people like closer to me right like I would want them working more closely than being totally separated um but I think it's totally possible like I don't know I think you can still have tight small teams uh you know when you're working remote I think it's doable I think it's the inter the inter-team stuff I think might be more complex yeah I think you know, I think you're totally right. I think it's kind of a weird way to sort of divide up the work.
比如：“好吧，你负责测试。你负责新开发。”这有点荒谬。但，是的，我猜这些问题在于：我们如何减少团队之间的摩擦，尤其是跨时区的摩擦？所以，如果我们假设数据库层是由东海岸甚至伦敦等地的人开发的，然后应用层是由西海岸的人开发的，
Like say, okay, you're responsible for tests. You're responsible for new developments. It's kind of bonkers. But yeah, I guess the questions are like, how do we reduce the friction between teams, especially across time zones so if you have let's say the database layer being developed in in the east coast or even in london or something and then the application layer being developed you on the west coast
嗯，我觉得这就是事情变得非常困难的地方。是的，所以我觉得时区问题与远程办公不同，我认为它们也许是进阶技能，就像是“高级技能”一样，对吧？——“好吧，你将拥有一个团队，而且你们会分散在各处，把团队维持在几个时区之内”——我的意思是，有人曾说过“至少要有四个小时的重叠时间”，但也许重叠时间还要更多一些，对吧？而且过去曾有过这样一种模式，我已经好几年没听过了，但人们过去常常谈论这种“全球接力式（follow the globe）”的软件开发模型，
um i think that's where things become really difficult yeah so like i think that time zones are different than working remotely and i think they're that maybe they're like the advanced they're like the advanced skill right like just yeah you're gonna have a team and you're gonna be all over the place like keeping in a couple time zones right like uh i mean somebody said like have at least four hours of overlap but but maybe have even more than that right um and there used to be like this model i haven't heard about it in years but you know people used to talk about like this like follow the globe software development model where
嗯，我觉得这就是事情变得非常困难的地方。是的，所以我觉得时区不同于远程办公，我觉得它们可能是……也许它们就像是进阶的，它们就像是高级技能，对吧？就像，是的，你要组建一个团队，而大家散落在各地，把时区控制在几个之内，对吧？呃，我的意思是，有人说过，至少要有四个小时的重叠时间，但也许甚至需要更多，对吧？呃，以前有一种模式，我已经好几年没听过了，但你知道，过去人们常谈论这种“全球接力”的软件开发模式，即
like somebody would work on something and then they'd hand it off to somebody like eight hours away who'd like work on it and then like i cannot foresee how that would actually work right like just yeah just have a team and just pretend even though you're all in each other's homes, that you work together, you know, closely and talk on Slack and get on video. And that's my advice. Yep. Yep. Yeah. We have a team in New York that we work with very closely. And there have been times when, over the past few years, when, you know, it's just like it needs rapid iteration. And it just feels like nothing is getting done because we'll suggest something a day later. It'll come back to us in a different format.
就像一个人在某个项目上工作，然后把它交接给八小时以外的某个人，让他继续推进，然后……我觉得我无法预见这到底该怎么运作。对吧？就像——是的，只要有一个团队，然后假装——尽管你们都在彼此的家里——你们在紧密合作，在 Slack 上交流，开着视频。这就是我的建议。没错。没错。对的。我们在纽约有一个团队，我们和他们合作非常紧密。在过去的几年里，有时会遇到这样的情况：你知道，这就像是需要快速迭代。而感觉却像什么都没做一样，因为我们提了一个建议，过了一天才以另一种格式反馈给我们。
And then we just play this really long like mail-in chess or something, right? And so finally, we just flew over there and spent a couple of weeks there and hashed it out. And so, yeah, I think maybe another piece of advice is if you're, well, under normal circumstances, non-COVID, if you're going to be working remote, you should kind of expect, or maybe you should not expect, but it's the other way around. Like you should encourage yourself to actually fly around and visit some people in real life. I i mean i think there's times when that is the answer and so um um i think that's you know beyond just the the social part
然后我们就像是在下一盘超长的远程国际象棋之类的，对吧？所以最后，我们直接飞过去在那儿呆了几个星期，把问题彻底讨论解决了。所以，是的，我想另一个建议是，如果你打算——当然是在正常情况下，非新冠疫情期间——如果你打算远程工作，你应该有所预期，或者也许你不该这么预期，但实际情况正好相反。就像你应该鼓励自己亲自坐飞机去到处看看，在现实生活中拜访一些人。我的意思是，我认为在某些情况下，这就是解决办法，所以……嗯……我认为这不仅仅是社交部分……
and doing the quarterly or annually get together um you know you should expect that like uh when you see this sort of trend of you know this sort of like impersonal like oh i'll get back to you tomorrow and then you know you should ping ponging like thisal like oh i'll get back to you tomorrow and then you know you should ping ponging like this did you say okay i'm gonna fly over there and let's like sit together for a week and um um you know and hopefully the place you're flying to has an office or there's some place you could both meet or something like that you're not flying to the other person's home with your luggage but uh um yeah i think that part is really important yeah the the place where i've seen things or a way that i've seen things go badly is yeah with these long iteration loops
除了做季度或年度的聚会……你知道，你应该预料到，当看到这种趋势——这种冷冰冰的“哦，我明天回复你”，然后你懂的，像这样来回拉锯。你说，“好吧，我要飞到那儿去，让我们坐在一起待上一周，然后……”你知道，希望你飞去的那个地方有个办公室，或者有什么地方你们俩都能碰面之类的，而不是带着行李飞到别人的家里去。但是，是的，我觉得那部分真的很重要。对，我看到事情出问题的地方，或者我看到事情进展不顺的一种方式，就是这种漫长的迭代周期。
and like you know like somebody who's like you know i'm working on two separate things because like i put together work on the one and then i have to get this other team to review it and then while i'm waiting two days for that i work on this other thing and one and then i have to get this other team to review it um and then while i'm waiting two days for that i work on this other thing and then and then like weeks go by where this person's just like slowly pushing forward two things and it's just like uh you know just talk to the people like yeah sometimes you you can't wait um yeah i don't know if you if you have to do a whole bunch of work in parallel to cover like really large lags, like you're, you're probably just covering up a huge problem. Yep. Yep. And you get a kind of feel for like the cadence for something,
就像——你知道的——有人会说：“我正在处理两件不同的事情，因为我把其中一件做好了，然后我得让另一个团队来审查，而在等待那两天的同时，我去做另一件事。”然后“我得让另一个团队来审查它”，然后在等待那两天的同时，我去做另一件事，然后……然后几周就这样过去了，这个人只是在慢吞吞地推进两件事，感觉就像是……你知道的，去和大家聊聊吧。是的，有时你等不及。是的，我不知道，如果你必须并行做一大堆工作来应对巨大的时间差，你可能只是在掩盖一个巨大的问题。没错。没错。你对某种事情的节奏会有所感觉，
you know, like you get a feel for like how the excitement curve, I guess of whatever it is you're working on. And so if, if you're working on something that you know, that, that, you know, you feel like you need to jump on it quickly, then, yeah, that's another reason to just let the folks know and say, look, like, let's set up a, you know, video chat. Let's set up a work chat or something where we have, like, more immediate, more loud, loud as in more notifications and all of that, like more loud communication so that we can just get this hashed out. And then other things that are, you know, maybe migrating the database. That's something that is not, doesn't require such a tight cadence. And so you can take forward to have the day back and forth communication. So Adam, we'll kind of wrap it up with, uh, what do you think will be
你知道的，就像你会对你正在做的任何事情的兴奋曲线产生一种感觉。所以，如果你正在做的事情，你知道的，让你觉得需要马上介入，那么，是的，这就是另一个原因，让大家知道并说：“听着，让我们安排一个视频聊天吧。让我们安排一个工作聊天或其他什么，在那里我们有更即时、更响亮的沟通——‘响亮’指的是更多的通知以及所有这些——这样我们就能把这事敲定。”而对于其他事情，比如迁移数据库，那是某种不需要如此紧凑节奏的事情，所以你可以花上一天时间来回沟通。那么，亚当，我们来总结一下，你认为……
the biggest change in work from home? Like if you were to look back five years from now and say, assuming you're still working from home for five, for the next five years, you know, what do you think would have changed the most? That's a good question. So when I first, so when I very first started working from home, like probably for the first couple months, we did our daily stand-up on a conference call. I phoned into it. And then quickly moved to Skype and so on. So I think with more and more people doing it, whatever communication mediums are probably going to get richer. So I don't know what's beyond like our current video, maybe just lower latency or easy. I don't really know, but I feel like communications
居家办公最大的变化会是什么？如果你从五年后的角度回头看，假设你在接下来的五年里仍然在居家办公，你认为什么变化会最大？这是一个好问题。所以，当我最初——当我刚开始在家办公时，大概头几个月里，我们在电话会议上开每日站会。我打电话接入。然后很快转到了 Skype 等等。所以我想随着越来越多的人这样做，无论什么沟通媒介都可能会变得更加丰富。所以我不知道超越我们当前视频的技术是什么，也许只是更低的延迟或更便捷。我真的不知道，但我感觉沟通
is the hard part of working distributed. So something to do with communication. Yeah, that makes sense. Patrick, what about you? Predictions for the work from home future, the work from the future home, WFFffh i feel like we've notoriously been not great at predicting future yeah yeah look at all the bitcoin we didn't buy and bigelow spacecraft oh man i still remember that inflatable hotel in this space um let's not talk about them uh so yeah i mean i think the normalization of work from home is sort of a given. I think we've been talking mostly about software engineering, but I mean, I think a lot of people are going to realize that a lot of work can be done from home. And if it means getting
是分布式办公中最难的部分。所以，这一定与沟通有关。是的，这说得通。帕特里克，你呢？对居家办公未来的预测，未来居家办公的……我感觉我们在预测未来这方面历来都不太擅长。对，对，看看我们没有买的那些比特币，还有毕格罗太空舱。哦，天哪，我还记得太空中那个充气酒店呢。我们别聊这个了……所以，是的，我认为居家办公的常态化可以说是板上钉钉的。我觉得我们之前主要在讨论软件工程，但我的意思是，很多人会意识到很多工作都可以在家里完成。如果这意味着获得
smaller offices for some types of businesses, I think that's going to be a pretty big win. If that cost of capital, wherever they are, is pretty expensive. The fact that we have to develop these tools and experiences now is going to have a trickle down effect to a lot of other more niche businesses that can take advantage of it. So I think that's an interesting trend to watch. Like, you know, just even thinking I'm trying to think of a crazy example, but management at Walmart, they would not necessarily have been able to do remote work before. But now maybe they can video conference into multiple stores, TV panels, and rally the troops beforehand because this video conferencing stuff has become cheap and better. So I think having video conferencing pop up in more places like that would be interesting. I also think there's going to be interesting changes in when people go to a doctor's office or hospital and getting triaging.
更小的办公室，对于某些类型的企业来说，我认为这是一个相当大的胜利。如果资本成本无论在哪里都很高的话。我们现在必须开发这些工具和体验，这将对许多其他可以利用它的更利基的企业产生涓滴效应。所以我认为这是一个值得关注的有趣趋势。就像，你知道，甚至试想一个疯狂的例子——沃尔玛的管理层，他们以前不一定能做到远程办公。但现在，也许他们可以通过电视屏幕视频会议连线多家门店，提前鼓舞士气，因为这种视频会议技术已经变得便宜且更好了。所以我觉得视频会议在更多类似的地方涌现会很有趣。我也认为，当人们去医生办公室或医院并进行分诊时，将会发生有趣的变化。
I think that's another outcome of this, but not necessarily exactly related to what you're saying. And I think the final trend, I guess, would be the desire of people to say, I have to have a dedicated office space where I live. So somewhere where I can put a desk and do this sometimes, I think will become a factor in where people choose to live. What do you think about WeWork? Do you think that WeWork will take over in the sense that everyone right now who's working from home could go to some local place, kind of like an Amazon locker, but for your office desk, right? You would just go to someplace close to you, but you'd still be working for a company that's far away. I mean, WeWork specifically has a whole bunch of problems with it, I guess. Yeah, yeah. Oh, my gosh. WeWork's a disaster. But just the idea that there's a desk you can rent, basically.
我认为这也是这一现象带来的另一个结果，但不一定与你刚才说的完全相关。我认为最后一个趋势，我想，会是人们的一种愿望，即：“我必须在我住的地方有一个专门的办公空间。”所以，一个我可以放一张桌子并在那里工作的地方，我认为这会成为人们选择居住地的一个因素。你对 WeWork 怎么看？你认为 WeWork 会接管市场吗？在这个意义上，现在每个在家办公的人都可以去某个本地的地方，有点像亚马逊快递柜，但却是为你的办公桌准备的，对吧？你只需去离你很近的某个地方，但你仍然在为一家远处的公司工作。我的意思是，WeWork 本身有很多问题，我猜。对，对。哦，天哪。WeWork 是个灾难。但仅仅是“有一个你可以租用的办公桌”这个想法。
I think that would make sense. There's a real estate capital model for it to work. But yeah, I mean, I think the fact of having someplace you could go like a library, but for doing video conferencing and a little bit of office work. I think there's a lot of potential there. Yeah. Yeah, it'd be kind of interesting. I mean, it would separate your social clique from your work clique. Like you would go to the WeWork and you and the buddies who work at all your competitors would play ping pong together in the office breaks, right? But yeah, I think my thing is, I feel like everything will become collaborative. You know, like, look at the VS Code. Have you seen the live code in VS Code?
我觉得这说得通。它有运作的房地产资本模型。但是，是的，我的意思是，拥有一个你可以去的地方——就像图书馆一样，但那是用来进行视频会议和一点办公的——我觉得那里有很大的潜力。对。对，那会挺有趣的。我的意思是，它会把你的社交圈子和你的工作圈子分离开来。就像你会去 WeWork，然后你和在所有竞争对手那里工作的好友们可以在办公室休息时一起打乒乓球，对吧？但是，是的，我觉得我的看法是，感觉一切都会变得具有协作性。你知道，就像看 VS Code 一样。你见过 VS Code 里的实时代码功能吗？
It's pretty amazing. It's awesome. Yeah, but I think, correct me if I'm wrong, Adam, but I think it's a broadcast model. So I don't think, you know, other people can edit your code when you invite them. It's just, they can just see what you're doing. And so I think the next step is where they could just write in your editor and then you could just extrapolate that to everything. Like maybe Excel has a button. When you press it, your coworker jumps into your spreadsheet and you're talking and he can also just add equations to it. Right. And so you can imagine every app, every enterprise app being like that. So VS Code is crazy good.
这太神奇了。太棒了。是的，但我觉得——如果我错了请纠正我，亚当——但我觉得它是一个广播模型。所以我不认为，你知道，当你邀请别人时，其他人可以编辑你的代码。他们只能看到你在做什么。所以我认为下一步就是他们可以直接在你的编辑器里书写，然后你可以把这推广到一切事物中。比如 Excel 可能有一个按钮。当你按下它时，你的同事就会跳进你的电子表格里，你们正在通话，他也可以直接往里面添加公式。对吧。所以你可以想象每个应用、每个企业级应用都是那样的。所以 VS Code 真是好得惊人。
Like, so you can type in it. You can both type in it. You can be in separate windows. Really? Okay. You can share your terminal so that the terminal window, like in VS Code, they can type in it. And like, if you launch like a local host or something
比如，你可以在里面打字。你们都可以同时在里面打字。你们可以在不同的窗口中。真的吗？好的。你可以共享你的终端，这样终端窗口——就像在 VS Code 中一样——他们可以在里面打字。而且，如果你启动了一个本地主机或其他什么，
on port something, something, you can like hit a button and it'll port forward it to them. So like if you're doing web like web development, you can load their local website into your browser remotely. So cool. Yeah. I mean, so I imagine just like modern enterprise apps being like that. I mean, especially Excel, which is probably the most popular enterprise app other than email, I guess. But yeah, that'd be my prediction. Well, so Adam, why don't you tell us a little bit, you know, we've talked so much about work from home. I think we've covered just about everything. Let me just check the chat now that I'm thinking about it to make sure we
在某个端口上，你可以点一个按钮，它就会将端口转发给他们。所以如果你在做网页开发，你可以远程把他们的本地网站加载到你的浏览器里。太酷了。是的，我的意思是，所以我可以想象现代企业级应用就是那样的。尤其是 Excel，它可能是除了电子邮件之外最受欢迎的企业级应用了，我猜。但是，是的，这就是我的预测。好吧，亚当，你为什么不给我们简单讲讲——你知道，我们聊了这么多关于居家办公的话题。我想我们几乎涵盖了所有方面。让我检查一下聊天记录，确保我们……
covered. It looks like we got everyone's questions. questions and yeah why don't you tell us a little bit about co-recursive so co-recursive has you said you've kind of updated the format a bit and so what kind of inspired that and what does it look like now yeah so yeah co-recursive is my podcast is kind of uh like a an interview format um so that the thing that i've that i've uh changed is i've tried to um i'm trying to kind of get people's stories, almost like case studies of building things, of doing software development and kind of present it in a format that's interesting to listen to. like i had a guy sean allen he came on and he explained how like he had to build this uh like high performance system where like you know every request had to be like within microseconds and like what kind of technology choices that kind of drove um you know like tried this that wouldn't work couldn't use jvm because the gc pause you know can't keep it within a microsecond um yeah i had
涵盖了。看起来我们收集了所有人的问题。问题是……是的，你为什么不给我们讲讲关于 Co-Recursive 的事呢？关于 Co-Recursive，正如你所说，你稍微更新了它的形式，那么是什么激发了这种灵感？现在它是什么样子的？是的，所以……是的，Co-Recursive 是我的播客，它有点像是一种访谈形式……所以我改变的地方在于，我试着去……我正试图捕捉人们的故事，几乎就像是构建事物的案例研究、进行软件开发的案例研究，并以一种听起来很有趣的格式呈现出来。就像我曾请来一位名叫肖恩·艾伦（Sean Allen）的嘉宾，他解释了他是如何构建这种高性能系统的，在这个系统中，你知道，每一个请求都必须在微秒级内完成，以及这推动了什么样的技术选择……你知道，尝试了这个却行不通，不能使用 JVM，因为垃圾回收（GC）暂停，你知道的，无法将其保持在微秒级……是的，我请过
like a twitter engineer um explaining how you know some of the keep it within a microsecond. Yeah, I had like a Twitter engineer explaining how, you know, some of the big data problems that they had, and then how he found some way to use like ideas from abstract algebra to actually solve kind of like real time data processing. And so I just released one today with Jim Blandy, who created a about like how he thought source control was broken, you know, back in 1993 and decided to build something better. So yeah, that's kind of my format change is to kind of embrace just like,
一位 Twitter 工程师，解释了你知道的他们的一些大数据问题，以及他是如何找到某种方法利用抽象代数的思想来实际解决实时数据处理问题的。所以我今天刚刚发布了一期节目，嘉宾是创建了……的吉姆·布兰迪（Jim Blandy），内容关于他在 1993 年左右如何认为源码管理系统坏掉了，并决定构建更好的东西。所以，是的，这就是我改变形式的地方，去拥抱，
I guess it's kind of the stories you might tell around the lunchroom, but I guess, you know, with everybody being remote, maybe you don't hear these stories. So I'm trying to find, you know, people who built interesting things, solved hard problems and kind of have them tell their story. So I guess like, yeah, if somebody is listening, and they have like a super interesting story of solving like a,
我想这有点像是你会在午休时讲的故事，但我想，你知道的，既然每个人都在远程办公，也许你就听不到这些故事了。所以我一直在寻找那些构建了有趣事物、解决了难题的人，并让他们讲述自己的故事。所以我想，是的，如果有人在听，并且他们有一个超级有趣的故事，关于解决了一个……
you know, a really hard problem or, you know, building something, and then it turns out that there was a much easier solution, you know, reach out to me. Maybe we could do have a show about you, your problem. Cool. What was the most exciting episode so far since you've changed the format? Oh, it's I mean, they're all exciting to me. Yeah. Yeah. But you have to pick a favorite. I'm kind of putting you on the spot. Yeah. Yeah. That's a good question. Yeah. So the Sean Allen one that I was just describing i thought was pretty interesting so yeah he you know he he worked on um uh i think it's apache storm which was like a real-time data processing thing yeah and then basically like some wall street types approached him and said like okay we need something like that but like this is high performance or
你知道的，一个真正困难的问题，或者构建了某个东西，结果发现有一个简单得多的解决方案，你知道的，联系我。也许我们可以做一期关于你、关于你的问题的节目。太酷了。自从你改变了节目形式以来，哪一期是最令人兴奋的？哦，我的意思是，对我来说每一期都很兴奋。对。对。但你必须选出一个最喜欢的。我有点把你架在火上烤了。对。对。这是个好问题。是的。所以我刚才描述的肖恩·艾伦那一期，我觉得挺有意思的。所以，是的，他……他曾在……我想是 Apache Storm 工作，这是一个类似于实时数据处理的东西。是的，然后基本上有一些华尔街类型的人找到他，对他说：“好吧，我们需要类似的东西，但这必须是高性能的”或
high frequency trading right so we're like we're in the microseconds. Yeah. And then so he kind of had to, he kind of takes us through like the tech choices that he had to make, right? Like, should I use C++? Should I use I can't use this, I can't use that, and kind of how he got. So I think he ended up with a solution where, you know, they're crunching numbers, like I think he said, like 80,000 calculations a second, and answering like hundreds of thousands of requests um that are all under a microsecond but but how he got there is like wow it's like super unusual i guess uh his path wow it's totally wild yeah the uh um the subversion one you know really resonated we've we've talked to a lot of programming language inventors and one of the things that I noticed is, you know, for many of us, like everyone, you know, has everyone who's worked
高频交易，对吧？所以我们是在微秒级。是的。然后他不得不，他带我们了解了他必须做出的技术选择，对吧？比如，我应该用 C++ 吗？我应该用……我不能用这个，我不能用那个，以及他是如何得出结论的。所以我想他最后找到的解决方案是，你知道的，他们在大规模进行数字计算，我想他说过，大概每秒 8 万次计算，并且响应数十万个请求，这些请求全都在微秒级以内。但是他是如何做到这一点的，简直是——哇，太不寻常了，我猜……他的经历。哇，完全太疯狂了。是的……子版本控制（Subversion）那一期，你知道，真的很有共鸣。我们和许多编程语言发明者聊过，我注意到的事情之一是，你知道，对我们许多人来说，每个人，你知道，在某种语言里工作过一段时间的人都会看到一些缺陷或他们不喜欢的东西。对。但我们大多数人都只是将就。对。甚至，你知道，有时你可能会遇到分析瘫痪（analysis paralysis），不知道该用什么语言来编写。随着时间的推移，你知道，我想至少我自己，我已经变得对这一点不置可否，更有可能直接挑选某种语言并开始工作。但我认为，你知道，要发明一门编程语言，你必须具备相反的心态。就像你必须带着这样的想法投入其中：“Python 有这个特性。我简直忍无可忍，
in a language for a while sees some flaw or something they don't like. Right. But most of us just deal with it. Right. And even, you know, there might be cases where you have sort of analysis paralysis where you don't know what language to write in. And over time, you know, I think at least myself, like I've gotten more ambivalent to that and more likely to just pick something and start working. But I think, you know, to invent a programming language, you have to have the opposite mindset. Like you have to go into it saying, you know, Python has this feature. I can't stand it. you know um it's driving me crazy i can't sleep at night and so i'm going to spend 5 000 hours writing a new language and popularizing it to the whole world uh you know because of that right and so it tends to attract like a certain type of
你知道，嗯……这快把我逼疯了，我晚上都睡不着觉，所以我打算花 5000 小时来编写一门新语言，并把它推广到全世界，你知道，就因为这个，”对吧？所以它往往会吸引某种特定类型的……
person that has just incredible like depth and and just amazing stories and uh just like a very sort of like hard-nosed attitude to uh to programming languages and i find those people like super fascinating to to talk to yeah jim's story like i'll give you just a tidbit so so jim he was so like cvs was the the main source control uh before subversion um and he worked at this place, they had a giant CVS repository. And like, if you want to create a branch in CVS, like it actually has to like make changes to every file to like create the branch. CVS has no transactions.
具有难以置信的深度、令人惊叹的故事以及对编程语言采取非常务实态度的个人，我发现和这些人交谈超级迷人。是的，吉姆的故事——我只透露一点给你们——所以吉姆，他曾经……在 Subversion 出现之前，CVS 是主要的源码管理系统，他在一个地方工作，他们有一个巨大的 CVS 仓库。而且，如果你想在 CVS 中创建一个分支，它实际上必须对每个文件进行修改来创建分支。CVS 没有事务处理机制。
So like, if somebody does a commit at the same time, like it's kind of like undefined what's going to happen. And the branch, like he was saying, it could take 45 minutes, could take two hours to make the branch because it has to go through hundreds of thousands of files. So he told the people there, he's like,
所以，如果有人同时进行提交（commit），就会发生某种未定义的情况。而这个分支，正如他所说，创建分支可能需要 45 分钟，可能需要两个小时，因为它必须遍历数十万个文件。所以他对那里的人说，
branching should be free. Nothing's actually changing, right? If you imagine this as a database, all we're doing is making a pointer that says this version here has this name. And they were like, yeah, sure, buddy. Like it's taken us hours. You say it should be free. Like, and they didn't believe him, but, but so he, uh, he went off and solved that problem. I mean, I think it took him years, but yeah, that's amazing. Very cool. All right. So yeah.
“分支应该是免费的。实际上没有任何东西改变，对吧？如果你把这想象成一个数据库，我们所做的只是创建一个指针，说明这里的这个版本有这个名称。”而他们说：“对，当然，老兄。这花 了我们几个小时。你说它应该是免费的。就像……”而且他们不相信他。但是，所以他……他去解决了那个问题。我的意思是，我想这花了他好几年时间，但，是的，这太棒了。非常酷。好吧。所以，是的。
Um, co-recursive so people can Google it.'ll also put a in the link to it in the show notes people can check it out and i'm assuming it's also on all the podcast engines like stitcher and google uh podcasts and all of those good good places yeah search for uh co-recursive or if that's hard to spell i could just put like adam gordon bell that's my name it should turn up the podcast as well cool awesome are you have you tried uh um spotify are you on spotify i think so i don't i assume but i'm not sure yeah yeah we got all of a sudden we got a lot of requests to be on spotify and so we set it up rather relatively recently and um it's actually a pretty awesome experience. So yeah, I think anytime we interview a fellow podcaster,
嗯，Co-Recursive，人们可以去谷歌搜索它。我也会在节目说明里放一个链接，人们可以去看看。而且我假设它也播出于所有的播客平台，比如 Stitcher 和谷歌播客以及所有那些好地方。是的，搜索“Co-Recursive”，或者如果那个很难拼写，我也可以直接写上“亚当·戈登·贝尔（Adam Gordon Bell）”，那是我的名字，应该也能搜到这个播客。太酷了，棒极了。你试过……嗯……Spotify 吗？你们在 Spotify 上吗？我想是的。我假设在，但我不确定。对，对，我们突然收到了很多要求在 Spotify 上线的请求，所以我们相对最近才把这个弄好，而且这实际上是一个相当棒的体验。所以，是的，我想每当我们采访同行的播客时，
we always tell them to check it out. But they recently signed some exclusive deals with some really, really big, big names in podcasts like Joe Rogan, I think, and someone else has an exclusive deal. And actually I found the interface and the analytics and all that pretty cool. So I'll have to check it out.
我们总是告诉他们去看看。但他们最近和一些播客界非常非常大牌的人物签署了一些独家协议，比如乔·罗根（Joe Rogan），我想还有其他人有独家协议。而且实际上我发现它的界面、分析工具以及所有这些都相当酷。所以我得去看看。
Yeah. Cool. All right. So everyone, thanks for have to check it out. Yeah. Cool. All right. So, you know, everyone, thanks for kind of checking it out, for supporting us on Patreon and all of that. Adam, thank you so much
是的。酷。好吧。所以，各位，感谢……得去看看。是的。酷。好吧。所以，你知道，各位，谢谢你们的关注，感谢你们在 Patreon 上对我们的支持以及所有这些。亚当，非常感谢你
for being on the show. You have a wealth of information on work from home and, you know, obviously super relevant to everybody. And I think it's going to continue to be relevant for most of us for a really long time. So I think it's going to continue to be relevant for most of us for a
来到节目中。你拥有关于居家办公的丰富知识，你知道，这显然与每个人都息息相关。而且我认为在很长一段时间里，它将继续与我们大多数人息息相关。所以我认为这在很长一段时间里，它将继续与我们大多数人
really long time. So I think this particular episode will have legs to it. I think it'll be relevant for many, many years. So unlike Rust, which we did a show on Rust like 0.1, and we're still getting emails about how none of it is relevant anymore and how we'll have to redo that. But I think work from home is something that will continue to resonate with people. And so thanks again for being on the show. Thank you. The intro music is Axo by Vynar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license.
息息相关。所以我觉得这一期节目会很有生命力。我认为它将在很多很多年里都保持相关性。所以，不像 Rust——我们曾为 Rust 0.1 版本做过一期节目，我们现在仍然收到电子邮件说里面的一切都不再相关了，我们必须重做那一期。但我认为居家办公是一个将继续引起人们共鸣的话题。所以再次感谢你来到节目中。谢谢。片头曲是由 Vynar Pilot 创作的《Axo》。《Programming Throwdown》在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。
You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work. under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混编和改编作品。在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混编和改编作品，但你必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。